Eine ganz blöde Frage. Ja. Sollen wir bei dem vornehmen, sie bleiben oder sollen wir uns duzen? Ich heiße Christa.
Wie sie oder du das wollen. Ich richte mich da komplett nach Riesen.
Mir ist das auch scheißegal.
Ja dann, wir wollen uns duzen. Ich bin der Max.
Du bist der Max. Ich bin die Christa. Max, will ich los?
Das ist doch schön.
Heute im Rasenfunk.
Dann hab ich gedacht, so, jetzt kann ich es aber alle gespielt. Dann hab ich ausgeholt, da hab ich alle vor den Kopf gehauen worden. Die Funk steht so wie ich dachte, muss nicht auf den Platz gehen. Weiß ich nicht, was die Kerle sich da ausgedacht haben im DFB. Weiß ich nicht, hat uns auch nicht interessiert, uns hat nur interessiert, wir spielen Fußball. Das war unser Lebenswichtiges. Lass mich das ruhig sagen, aber es war die Zeit. Ich kann nur eins sagen, es waren die zehn schönsten Jahre meines Liebes. So war es.
Das Tribünengespräch.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr hier im Tribünengespräch vom Rasenfunk gelandet seid. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Etge Netzer in allen sozialen Netzwerken und freue mich wirklich sehr, dass ihr diese Folge hier hört. Ihr habt den unmittelbaren Teil vor Beginn des Interviews mit Christa Kleinhans. Den habt ihr schon gehört und gleich geht auch das eigentliche Interview los. Wie ihr es vom Tribünengespräch gewohnt seid, wird das einfach in einem durchgesendet, so wie ich das Gespräch geführt habe. Weil wir allerdings auch noch ein bisschen gesprungen sind, sowohl in der Zeitleiste, in der Biografie von Christa Kleinhans, dachte ich, ich mache diese kurze Einführung hier an dieser Stelle, damit ihr euch im Gespräch auch besser zurechtfindet. Also ein paar wichtige Daten zu Christa Kleinhans, die eine Pionierin des deutschen Fußballs ist. Sie ist am 22. Juli 1937 in Dortmund geboren. Sie ist damit der älteste Gast, den wir jemals hatten im Rasenfunk. Also in nicht einmal einem Monat wird sie 88 Jahre alt. Und sie hat Fußball gespielt, nachdem sie erst mit Leichtathletik begonnen hat, im Alter von 18 Jahren. Und sie hat zwischen 1955 und 1965 für Fortuna Dortmund gespielt und hat rund 150 Länderspiele absolviert. Das waren noch keine offiziellen Länderspiele, denn wir alle wissen, der DFB hat damals alles getan, um den Frauenfußball-Steine in den Weg zu legen, hat ihn innerhalb seiner Strukturen verboten und ist damit den Frauen auch viel, viel schwieriger gemacht, Plätze zu finden, Schiedsrichter zu finden, auch andere Teams zu finden, gegen die man spielen kann. Diese Geschichte, sie muss erzählt werden. Der DFB würde gerne anfangen, erst später über den Frauenfußball zu sprechen. Aber gerade anlässlich dieser Europameisterschaft jetzt lohnt sich doch ein Blick auf die Zeit davor und eben ein Blick auf Menschen wie Christa Kleinhans. Wie sie tickt, ihr habt schon ein bisschen im Intro gehört, ihr werdet gleich das ganze Gespräch mit ihr hören. Man kann sie auch sehen, wenn euch das interessiert. Es gibt eine sehr empfehlenswerte Doku von Thorsten Körner, wurde die produziert. Für die ARD-Mädchen können kein Fußball spielen. Ich werde es euch in den Show notes verlinken. Diese Doku wird auch nach dem deutschen Länderspiel am Freitagabend im Linian-Fernsehen gezeigt. Aber für alle hippen Leute gibt es natürlich auch den Link in die Mediathek. Wir sprechen auch in dem Interview, dass ihr jetzt dann gleich hört, kurz über Mädchen können kein Fußball spielen. Und ansonsten nur der eine Hinweis an dieser Stelle. Wir haben an zwei, drei Stellen eine kurze Pause gemacht. Einmal konnte ich es auch nur so schneiden, dass man es noch kurz hört. Und ihr werdet vielleicht auch merken, wir haben an einem der heißesten Tage dieses Jahres aufgenommen. Es war wirklich unwahrscheinlich. Und auch deswegen bin ich jetzt nicht bei jedem Thema wirklich in die Tiefe gegangen, denn ich wollte Christa, die ich ja duzen darf, hört man auch damit, dass ich das die ersten paar Mal dann noch falsch gemacht habe, aber ich wollte ihr dann auch atträglich gestalten, weil sie war unheimlich nett mir gegenüber und sie hätte auch noch länger gesprochen. Aber ich hatte den Eindruck, irgendwann hatte dieses Gespräch dann auch mal so sein Ende erreicht. Deswegen, wir konnten nicht in jedes Thema tief reingehen. Und Christa hat auch immer wieder betont, das werdet ihr gleich hören, und sie erinnert sich auch nicht mehr an jedes Detail noch in der allerklarsten Schärfe. Aber es war dennoch ein unheimlich faszinierendes Gespräch. Ich hoffe auch für euch und dann würde ich doch sagen genug mit meinem Gelaber. Ich melde mich nach dem Interview nochmal. Jetzt legen wir aber los mit dem, was quasi unmittelbar nach dem passiert ist, was ihr ganz am Anfang dieser Sendung gehört habt. Und bitte. Christa Kleinhans ist hier. Ich freue mich sehr. Ich darf auch schon du sagen. Also herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk, Christa.
Ja, also ich finde das ganz toll, dass wir uns duzen. Das ist eigentlich auch so bekannt auf diesen ganzen Wege, die ich in den Jahren gemacht habe, wenn ich mal interviewt wurde. Und es war immer wunderschön, wenn man sich geduzt hat. Das Vornehme-Sie war weg.
Ist ihr auch so ein bisschen Ruhepott, oder? Sich zu duzen, oder?
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich habe da keine Erfahrung so. Ich kann da nicht. Ich kann das nicht bestätigen.
Sie haben keine Erfahrung. Sie wohnen doch ihr Leben. Ihre 87, fast 88 Jahre wohnen sie doch schon.
Ja, nicht so lange. Ich glaube seit 1993, weiß ich genau. Na ja, ist auch ganz egal.
Aber waren Sie mal aus dem Ruhrgebiet raus?
Eigentlich nicht. Ich bin im Ruhrgebiet geboren worden 1937. Dann kam der Krieg. Dann wurden wir evakuiert in den Schwarzwald. Ich glaube, das war 42 oder 43. Nee, eher glaube ich 40 oder 41. Ich will mich jetzt nicht festlegen. Aber es war eine schöne Zeit, wo ich als Kind im Schwarzwald war. Und nach Beendigung des Krieges sind wir in ein Waggon gekommen. Sind vier Wochen von Hasslach im Kindsrichtal nach Dortmund. Haben wir vier Wochen gebraucht. Zwischendurch ist ein Waggon, wo meine Mutter saß. Und wir saßen auch an diesem großen Fenster. Es war ja kein Fenster, es war eine Tür. Wir sind umgekippt. Meine Mutter hatte Verbrennungen von dem heißen Wasser. Man konnte an so einem kleinen Ölchen kochen. Aber im Grunde genommen ist alles noch prima gewesen. Man hat uns dann rausgeholt. Und dann kamen wir in einen anderen Waggon rein. Und naja, so peu à peu näherten wir uns dann dort und aber jetzt fragt mich nicht, was da jetzt alles danach gewesen ist. Das habe ich nicht mehr. Ja, ich war ja noch ein Kind.
Ja, acht Jahre dann.
Ja, genau. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich kann mich nur an dieses Unglückzug Unglück. Warum der Waggon umgekippt ist, weiß ich auch nicht. Vielleicht habe ich es damals gewusst, aber jetzt weiß ich es nicht mehr. Es ist Gott sei Dank nichts passiert. Wir sind alle glücklich davongekommen. Meine Mutter hatte zwar vom Wasser so Verbrennungen am Arm, aber später hatte sie keine Narben, dass das irgendwie eine Erinnerung war, was damals passiert war. Nee, hatte sie nicht. Es ist alles gut gegangen.
Und kannst du dich noch dran erinnern, wie das dann war, hier in Dortmund anzukommen? Das muss ja auch komplett anders ausgesehen haben. Du hast später mal gesagt, wenn wir dann zum Fußball kommen, dass ihr auf der einen Seite Fußball gespielt habt und auf der anderen Straßenseite die Kriegströmer lagen.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube 1946. 1946 kamen wir hier an. Es lag alles in Trümmern. Und mein Vater hatte sich einquartiert in dem Haus, wo auch er 1910 geboren wurde. Da hatte er noch zwei Geschwister wohnen. Und die haben uns aufgenommen. Wir kamen in den vierten Stock. Wir konnten in den Himmel gucken. Mein Vater hatte alles besorgt, damit oben alles dicht wurde. Ja, und so hat man so von Jahr zu Jahr fortgeschritten.
Aber das heißt, du hattest einen Vater, der dann auch schon wieder da war?
Nee, ich weiß nicht, wann mein Vater gekommen ist. Ich hab den im Fluor habe, bin ich dem ihm. Der hatte noch seinen Anzug an. Das war aber schon Frieden mit 45. Ich hab den erst gar nicht erkannt. Der sah so komisch aus. Guck mir an, er guckt mich an. Und dann hat er mich umarmt. Ja, da wusste ich, das ist mein Papa. Das sind alles so Erinnerungen, weißt du? Die musst du abspeichern können. Die musst du richtig in deinem Gehirn. Kommt ja noch, wenn du älter wirst, Jahrzehnte danach. Hast du das denn dann noch mitgekriegt und so? Das war auch so eine Situation, die ich nicht vergesse. Mein Vater da im Militäranzug, da zu sehen. Ja, das muss ich einen Punkt machen, weil ich jetzt auch nicht mehr weiß, wie ist so pöö pöö. Das Dach wurde dann repariert und viel wurde in der Wohnung gemacht. Es war die schreckliche Zeit nach dem Krieg, wo jeder was zu machen hatte, reparieren konnte und so weiter. Das gehörte einfach zum normalen Leben dazu. Und ich als Kind wurde dann eingeschult auch. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht nach wie vielen Jahren habe ich so eine Aufnahmeprüfung für die Realschule gemacht und habe dann da sechs Jahre Realschule gemacht, und bin mit der betre Reife entlassen worden. Und bin dann bei der Post angefangen als Angestellte. Erst fünf Jahre, glaube ich, war ich beim Fernamt. Da wurde alles noch handvermittelt, ja. Nicht wie alles jetzt so vollständig.
Hast du das Fräulein vom Amt, das eben die Verbindung herstellt?
Ja, genau. Wenn du mich von zuhause auch, ich möchte gerne nach München oder nach Stuttgart, ja, ich verbinde, ja. Dann erst mal alles notiert, deine Telefonnummer, ja. Und dann wurde die Verbindung hergestellt, da bin ich da reingegangen, Stuttgart oder München. Ich hätte gerne in München die und die Nummer. Ja, dann wurde die Verbindung hergestellt. So war das damals.
Und wie viel hat man da mitgehört als Fräulein vom Amt? Ich kenne das nur als diese Phrase.
Nein, man wurde kontrolliert. Da saß oben jemand, die hat sich immer so einzelne da rausgepickt und hat das alles aufgenommen, was ich gequatscht habe und was der gesagt hat, der da angerufen hat. Ja, das war dann so. Und wenn ihr was nicht gefallen hat, dann musste man nach oben kommen und dann wurde man gemassert. Auch das nur nebenbei gemerkt. Das sind alles Zeiten, weißt du, da kannst du mit deinen jüngeren Jahren nicht mitreden. Ist auch gut so. Du bist in einer anderen Welt, die fortgeschrittener war, bist du groß geworden. Ich will dir nur sagen, ich bedauere das nicht, die ich als Kindheit verbracht habe. Meine Eltern haben mir alles erfüllt. Einzelkind war ich. Die wussten, dass ich so eine Fußballbiene bin, dass ich mit den Jungs lieber spielen würde, als mit einem Püppchen im Arm und dann irgendwo, ach, da ist auch noch eine, die tickt so wie du. Das wäre widerlich für mich gewesen. Ich war nicht als Mädchen der Typ, der mit Puppen spielen wollte. Und hätte man mir eine Puppe geschenkt, dann wäre ich aber beleidigt gewesen. Hätte man mir aber einen Ball geschenkt, dann hätte ich den umarmt. So war die Zeit damals, weißt du?
Aber weißt du, warum deine Eltern so waren? Das ist ja durchaus untypisch für die damalige Zeit, dass ihnen das eigentlich egal war, welches Rollenklischee du erfüllst.
Ja, das weiß ich nicht. Kann ich in den Kopf meiner Eltern, das hat mich auch gar nicht interessiert. Mir wurde das erfüllt, wo ich als Kind immer von geträumt habe, Fußball zu spielen. Ich habe es gekriegt und vielleicht kann ich dir das erzählen, wie ich dazugekommen bin, in einer Mannschaft zu spielen.
Ja, lass uns da noch nicht hinkommen. Ich habe noch mehr Fragen. Erzähl weiter. Wenn man sich zum Beispiel mit anderen Fußballer-Biografien, das sind dann eben leider immer Männer bisher beschäftigt.
Männer waren sie noch nicht.
Aber die damals Jungs waren, als du ein Kind warst. Ja, ja. Dann merkt man, dass das ein ganz, es gibt so eine Dichotomie. Auf der einen Seite wurden Kinder damals für ganz viele Arbeiten eingebunden, mussten sich stundenlang anstellen, gerade in den großen Hungerjahren, direkt nach dem Krieg. Und auf der anderen Seite war es aber auch eine unheimliche Freiheit, weil die Eltern gar nicht die Möglichkeit hatten, sich um sie zu kümmern. Das heißt, Kinder haben auch stundenlang unbeaufsichtigt in den Trümmern gespielt. Wie war es bei dir?
So war das bei mir. Ich kann mich erinnern, es lag ja alles in Trümmern. Da sind vier Kinder in die Trümmern gegangen, haben Hämmerchen gehabt. Und dann haben wir die Steine, die Ziegelsteine, die haben wir von dem, was da noch dran klebte, haben wir abgehauen. Und dann haben wir die Ziegelsteine, die schön sauber waren, sofern es ging, wurden natürlich nicht gewaschen oder was. Aber die waren befreit von dem Zement und was für alles da dran war. Ich glaube, wir haben zwei Pfennig gekriegt pro Ziegel. Ich weiß es nicht ganz genau, das lassen wir mal so ein bisschen offen. Aber mir hafte so was im Kopf, dass wir das nicht umsonst gemacht haben, sondern wir haben uns gefreut, wenn wir für die Ziegelsteine zwei Pfennige bekommen haben. Weißt du, das ist eine Zeit, da kannst du nur drüber schmunzeln und sagen, Gott sei Dank, dass ich diese Zeit nicht erlebt habe. Aber wenn ich rückblickend schaue, das sind jetzt so 70 Jahre zurück, ich hatte eine wunderbare Kindheit, die mir auch meine Eltern schenken. Die wussten, dass Mädchen, das will ich mit Puppenspiel, der schenken wir mal einen Ball. Dann sind wir auf die Kirmes gegangen, da hat mein Vater an der Bude so einen Ball geschossen. Da war ich ganz stolz.
War das dein erster Ball?
Mein erster Ball.
Den kannst du dich bestimmt noch gut erinnern. Ich erinnere mich ja sogar an mein erster Ball.
Ich war ganz stolz. Ich nahm also den Ball von mir ab, mit zu den Jungs. Christa hat einen Ball, lass uns pölen. Dann haben wir gepölt und so. Auf einmal war der Ball verschwunden.
Ach Gott, das war der Ball, der verschwunden ist.
Der war weg. Wir haben den Ball gesucht. Ich weiß gar nicht, wer den geklaut hat. Weiß ich nicht. Mein schöner Ball, mein Geschenk von der Kirmes, was mein Vater geschossen hat, war weg. Das nur neben dem Ball bemerkt. Das haftet auch an meiner Erinnerung.
Und dazu muss man ja sagen, Ball war damals was besonderes. Ihr habt wahrscheinlich mit allem möglichen gespielt. Du hast mir in einem Interview erzählt, ihr habt aus Zeitungen Bälle gepaart.
Das wollte ich gerade sagen. Oder aus Lumpen. Haben wir das umwickelt, die Lumpen, und dann haben wir damit gepölt. Oder, wie du schon sagtest, geformt so mit Zeitungspapier, wie wir das alles so gemacht haben, weiß ich nicht. Hauptsache, es war rund und man konnte pölen damit. Das war so nicht nur ein Wunschgedanke von mir, Fußball zu spielen, sondern die Jungs, die mit waren aus der Nachbarschaft, die waren auch alle glücklich, dass sie so ein Bällchen hatten. Ja, das glaube ich.
Aber du hast jetzt gerade schon hier mit deinem rechten Fuß ausgeholt, während du mir den Ball erklärt hast. Also dir steckt der Fußball immer noch im Blut. Ich merke das jetzt schon.
Entschuldigung, weißt du was? Ich bin natürlich jetzt im Ende weg von der Jugend. Ich habe auch die zehn Jahre von 55 bis 65 genossen und später auch die zehn Jahre Handball. Hätte ich noch einen Wunsch, könnte den realisieren, würde ich mich 70 Jahre jünger machen. Und ich denke immer vom Talent, was ich hatte, hätte ich vielleicht eine Chance, bei der jetzigen Nationalmannschaft zu spielen. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich will nicht eingebildet sein. Ich gehe nur davon aus, wie gut ich war als Jugendliche. Später als heranwachsende Frau hatte ich mein Talent nicht verloren. Denn da gab es die Möglichkeit, dass wir doch irgendwo trainieren konnten. Nicht auf Tore schließen, sondern wir haben geguckt, wo ist eine freie Fläche? Dann sind wir in den Höschpark gegangen, haben die Maulwürfhügel alle plattgetreten, wir hatten eine große Wiese. Oh, wie war das schön. Jetzt habe ich einen Satz schon weiter gemacht. Um dahin zu kommen, war das folgendermaßen. Ich ging abends so spazieren, Fernsehen gab es noch nicht. Dann machte man so seine Runde. Man wurde auch nicht irgendwie belästigt oder was. Man ging so durch Hörde, machte da seine Kurve, ging zu Kinos, da guckte sich die Bilder an. Und da begegnete mir eine, die gestern auch noch da war, die Inge Quast. Und die sprach mich an, hör mal, du hast nicht Lust Fußball zu spielen? Ja, du kannst Fußball spielen bei Grün-Weiß-Dortmund. Soll ich dich mal mitnehmen? Ja, kannst du machen. Dann bin ich hingegangen. Dann haben wir da im Körner, war das Dortmund-Körner, auf dem Fußballplatz. Da sah ich die Mädchen, die da rumpölten. Weißt du was? Da habe ich gedacht, da willst du Fußball spielen? Ich wusste ja, was ich konnte. Die waren alle verrückt, wollten Fußball spielen, aber das Talent hatten sie nicht. Entweder haben sie eine Kiste getreten worden oder was weiß ich. Es hat mir nicht gefallen, da habe ich zu ihr gesagt, nee, da gehe ich nicht rein. Kurz darauf wurde der zweite Verein in Dortmund gegründet, Fortuna Dortmund. Richtig, eine Freundin da, du sagst, hast du nicht Lust, bei uns zu spielen? Ich habe natürlich hingegangen, da sah ich die Mädchen, die hatten ein Gefühl in den Beinen, die können Fußball spielen. Da meldest du dich an. Da hatte ich eine wunderschöne Zeit, wunderschöne Jahre. Das sind manche Jahre, die Jahrzehnte zurückliegen. Ich basiere jetzt mal auf 70 Jahre, das wäre 55 gewesen, wo ich angefangen bin, Fußball zu spielen. Jetzt haben wir 25. Oder gehen wir mal ein bisschen weiter, dann sind es 60 Jahre. Also ich will mich jetzt nicht auf irgendein Jahrzehnt festlegen. Ich will nur sagen, so nach und nach holte man uns eigentlich raus. Und daran kann ich mich auch erinnern, das habe ich auch festgeknagelt im Kopf. Da waren zwei Männer aus Köln, zwei Reporter. Da war ich auch später mit denen nochmal zusammen. Die haben mich dann interviewt. Die haben das irgendwie rausgekriegt, dass es zu der Zeit Mädchenfußball gab. Und da haben die sich an mich gewandt, mich angerufen, ob ich nicht bereit wäre, eine Ausguff zu geben. Ich kann mich jetzt nicht auf das Gespräch festlegen, weil ich das nicht mehr weiß. Die waren sehr nett. Die haben mich ausgefragt und so weiter. Und dann haben die auch gesagt, ich glaube, dass man einmal ein, ach, das ist alles schon so weit zurück. Ich weiß nicht, ob die auch den Rundfunk, also Fernsehen noch nicht den Rundfunk Bescheid gesagt haben. Also das streichen wir mal lieber, weil ich mir nicht so genau sagen kann. Mensch, war das wirklich so? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich will auch nicht, wenn ich diese Reportage gebe, will ich nicht lügen. Ich will an die Zeit die Menschen aufklären, wie es damals gewesen ist. Was uns so viel Freude gemacht hat, dass man so lange Fußball gespielt hat. Und es wurde so peu à peu immer besser. 1970 war das Verbot aufgehoben worden und der DFB, der passte das überhaupt nicht. Nur der DFB, der kriegte Bescheid von den Mädchen. Ich glaube, es waren mehr als 100.000, die Fußball spielen wollten. Und dann haben sie gesagt, da müssen wir Frieden schließen mit denen. Da müssen wir jetzt das Verbot aufheben.
Weißt du, was auch eine Rolle gespielt hat? Es war nicht nur der DFB.
Ich war nicht mehr dabei.
Die FIFA hat dem DFB gesagt, also hat es allen Verbänden gesagt, ihr müsst jetzt den Frauenfußball integrieren bei euch, denn es gab ja den Westdeutschen Damenfußballverband, aber es gegründete sich auch schon ein deutscher.
Du, entschuldige mal, ich glaube, der Westdeutsche, der ist 58, ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt richtig liege, ist der gegründet worden. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, 57 habe ich gelesen, so um den Dreh rum.
Ja, ja, so ungefähr.
Und deswegen, und weil aber die FIFA sich geweigert hat, zwei Verbände aus derselben Nation anzunehmen, denn der Damenfußballverband, so wie er damals hieß, der Deutsche, hat versucht, in der FIFA aufgenommen zu werden, hat die FIFA gesagt, und zwar an allen Verbänden, die die Thematik war, in Belgien, Italien, England, gleich haben sie gesagt, ihr müsst das machen. Also so, weil der DFB ist ja jetzt ganz gerne dabei zu sagen, ja, dann haben wir es ja dann auch erkannt. Aber ganz so freiwillig haben sie das nicht erkannt. Aber das würde mich nämlich auch mal interessieren. Also weil wir sind ja jetzt schon ein bisschen in der Zeit nach vorne gesprungen. Also du warst 18 Jahre, als du dann eben zu Fortuna Dortmund gekommen bist. Und gleichzeitig hast du von Beginn an mit den Jungs auf der Straße Fußball gespielt.
Dann nicht mehr.
Ja, dann logischerweise.
Logischerweise. Ich war ja froh, dass ich eine Mannschaft hatte, wo ich Fußball spiele. Und wir waren eigentlich sehr gut bestückt, so vom Talent her. Sonst, also irgendwie war ich ja auch, wie soll man das sagen? Aber man will ja dann auch in einer Mannschaft spielen, die auch Fußball spielen können. Es gibt natürlich Klassenunterschiede, aber der Wille war da, die hatten auch Talent. Aber naja, der eine hat mehr Talent als der andere. Ja, so war es damals auch bei uns.
Und ja auch die Möglichkeit zu spielen. Du hast halt viel mit den Jungs auf deiner Straße gespielt, Straßenecke gegen Straßenecke. Wann ist dir denn das dann zum ersten Mal so richtig aufgefallen, dass die Jungs ja dann durchaus die Möglichkeit hatten, in den Verein zu gehen, deine Gleichaltrigen mit, ich weiß nicht, 10, 11, 12, 13? Und für dich gab es diese Möglichkeit nicht?
Du, ich weiß nicht, wo die Jungs alle geblieben sind. Wir wohnen ja von Jahr zu Jahr älter. Jungs hatten andere Interessen, guckten vielleicht schon mal nach Mädchen. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich will das jetzt auch nicht negativ beurteilen können, aber wir hatten keine Verbindung mehr. Wir grüßen uns wohl noch so. Aber einige, die machten dann auch noch ihr Realabschluss oder das Abitur machten die. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich kann mich da nicht hineindenken, was aus denen geworden ist. Kann ich nicht mehr. Mich hat dann nur interessiert, ich kann in einer Mannschaft Fußball spielen. Da ist endlich ein Wunsch bei mir in Erfüllung gekommen. Ja, und dieser Wunsch, der hat sich so fest genagelt. Ja, das war das Schönste, was mir als Mädchen passieren konnte.
Hast du denn dich damals dann als junges Mädchen auch für diese Themen interessiert, die dahinterstehen? Wir sind ja jetzt in der Zeit. Die Gründungsväter und Mütter des Grundgesetzes haben ja die Gleichberechtigung von Frau und Mann ins Grundgesetz geschrieben, aber eine Fristgesetz, bis zu der das umgesetzt hätte werden müssen. Die Frist haben die Männer dann erst mal verstreichen lassen, bevor sie nochmal dran erinnern werden mussten. Und dann ging es langsam los, aber es war immer Gleichbehandlung, war noch keine Gleichbehandlung. Also ich habe zum Beispiel nochmal, das hatte ich schon wieder komplett vergessen, du als Spätere dann Verbeamtete hattest, doch bestimmt hattest du die Celebatsklausel noch im Kopf, dass eine Beamtin sofort entlassen werden muss, wenn das Familieneinkommen dazu reicht, die Familie zu ernähren.
Das ist mir völlig freundlich, was du gesagt hast.
Aber hattest du solche Themen im Blick damals?
Nein, weißt du was? Wenn ich jetzt in meinen Beruf gehe als Beamtin, da war ich ja noch beim Fernamt, ich hatte Wechseldienst, ich hatte auch an vier Tagen, je nachdem, vielleicht von Weihnachten einen Tag oder Heiligabend, das war alles so bestückt. Man hatte jeden Tag eine andere Schicht. Man hatte sich daran gewöhnt. Eigentlich habe ich meinen Beruf gelebt. Aber wenn es in die Fußballzeit ging, dann habe ich erstmal mit dem Manager da gesprochen und habe gesagt, ich würde da gerne so zehn D-Mark geben, wenn die für mich an dem Tag meinen Dienst übernehmen würde. Das übernehmen würde heißt, ich revanchiere mich und übernehme von ihr irgendwann mal ihren Dienst. So war das. Und da bin ich gut mit klargekommen. Ich hatte da nie Schwierigkeiten. Ich habe denen dann das Geld gegeben, ich bin irgendwie zum Floritsing gegangen. Dann hat er mir zehn D-Mark gegeben. Und dann habe ich den Mädchen das gegeben. Und die haben sich gefreut, dass sie zehn D-Mark kriegt. So war das. Es war alles anders. Wieder meine Aussage, alles. Es war alles anders. Aber für mich war das schön, eine schöne Zeit. Die könnt ihr gar nicht so nach kontrollieren, nachfolgen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich sagen sollte, ihr habt was verpasst. Weiß ich nicht. Kommt immer drauf an, was hast du für ein Elternhaus gehabt? Was hast du für Geschwister gehabt? Sind die dafür oder nicht dafür? Musst du kämpfen, damit du Fußball spielen kannst? Ja, ich brauchte nicht zu kämpfen, weil mein Vater wusste, dass ich gut Fußball spielte und war eigentlich auch ein stolzer Papa. Und das hat er in seinem Fußballverein, hat er wohl auch kundgetan. Ja, aber dann, jetzt muss ich was Negatives sagen. Ich hab in Hörde gespielt, dass endlich, Gott mir mal in Hörde meiner Geburt statt, Gott mir Fußball spielen am Schallacker Isters.
Also da mit Fortuna Auswärtsspiel in Hörde.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, mit unseren. So, und wir hatten dann gegen Holland gespielt. Und ich kriegte immer was auf die Socken. Ich war, erstes Mal war ich schnell, war ich, ich konnte gut Fußball spielen. Dann hat die mir in die Knochen gehauen. Und das habe ich mir eine ganze Zeit gefallen lassen. So, und dann habe ich gedacht, so, jetzt können wir es aber alle geschmiert haben. Dann habe ich ausgeholt, da habe ich einem vor den Kopf gehauen worden. Wie voll steht es mich da? Muss ich vom Platz gehen. Mein Vater, der war wütend auf mich, dass seine Tochter, die er so rumgetragen hat, was das für ein tolles Mädchen ist, die kann Fußball spielen und das. Da fliegt er vor dem Platz. Der kam nach Hause und da hat er mir Bescheid gegeben. Aber frag nicht, wie er geschimpft hat, dass ich ihn als Vater blamiert habe. Wie konntest du das nur machen? Mir sind die Nerven durchgegangen, weil ich immer wieder was vor den Sticken kriegte. Und da habe ich einfach ausgeholt, weil ich nicht mehr richtig im Kopf war. Ich weiß es nicht. Und dann durfte ich duschen gehen. Das war das Negative. Aber sonst alles immer positiv. Ich weiß, dass ich angesprochen wurde. Ich hatte sogar einmal zweimal von Jugendlichen, da habe ich noch woanders gebohrt mit meinen Eltern, dass diese spät abends auf einmal anschelten wollen. Ich kannte die Jungs gar nicht. Dann haben sie sich vorgestellt. Da habe ich gesagt, tut mir leid, ich kann euch nicht unterbringen. Aber ich bin bemüht, rufen wir ein Hotel an. Das haben sie sich dann auch erlaubt. Dann sind die ins Hotel gezogen, haben da genechtigt und dann habe ich von denen auch nie mehr was gehört.
Aber was wollten die das, habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Das weiß ich nicht. Wir sind ja gar nicht ins nähere gekommen.
Aber du warst eine Bekanntheit.
Ja, das war es eben. Und dann wollten die mich irgendwie ausfragen. Ich weiß es nicht. Es ist jetzt nur eine Vermutung von mir. Könnte so gewesen sein. Aber ich weiß nichts Näheres. Ja. Und dann hatte ich aber eine wunderschöne Verbindung in Würzburg. Der hat einen Weinberg. Moment, wie heißt dieses Weingebiet? Um Würzburg herum. Komm jetzt nicht drauf.
Es gibt viele.
Mensch, dünner Wetter nochmal. Das fällt mir jetzt nicht ein. Auf alle Fälle, der schickte mir immer wunderschöne Pakete. Der hatte mich auch, wie hab ich, zwei oder dreimal in Würzburg gespielt. Der war immer glücklich, wenn er die Christa sah. Da konnte er mich begrüßen und hatte Spaß. Der alte Mann, das war ein Apotheker im Ruhestand. Der freute sich, wenn er mich gesehen hatte. Ich war auch freundlich zu ihm, denn das war er mir wert. Wie soll ich das jetzt sagen? Kann ich schlecht sagen? Er war sehr, sehr lieb, sehr nett. Dann hat er nach meiner Adresse gefragt. Dann hab ich gedacht, er wird mir wohl mal schreiben. Oder was weiß ich. Da kriegte ich laufend Pakete gefüllt mit allem drum. Mit Kaffee, mit Fleisch, mit Boxbeutel.
Ja, genau.
Mit Boxbeutel, ja. Und ich weiß nicht, was sonst noch drin war. Ja, was hab ich gemacht? Ich hab mich richtig gefreut und hab gedacht, Mensch, das geht doch mal, das darf es doch wohl nicht. Der hat dich so lieb und nett begrüßt. Und wir haben auch nett miteinander gesprochen, kurz gesprochen, dass er dir Paket schickt. Ja, und nach dem Paket, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie oft dann noch so Pakete kamen. Immer mit Erfüllung. Und der Mann, der war so glücklich, dass er mit mir eine Verbindung aufgebaut hatte. Ja, er war schon älter. Oh Mann, der war bestimmt. Der war schon, er war nicht mehr aktiv als Apotheker. Also muss er auch schon in die Mitte 60 gewesen sein.
Und du noch ein junges Mädchen.
Ja, ich war noch knackig damals. Und auf einmal, wie ich weiß auch jetzt gar nicht, ach so, da kriegte ich von seiner Frau Bescheid, dass er tot ist. Ich könnte aber zur Beerdigung mitkommen. Dann habe ich überlegt, ich war ja noch berufstätig, sollst du nach Würzburg fahren und so? Und nein, ich bin nicht hingefahren, ja. Und dann hat sich das alles geebnet. Die Frau wollte, der hatte auch ein Enkelkind noch. Die Frau wollte wohl mit mir nichts mehr zu tun haben. Das kann man jetzt nehmen, wie man will. Das ist mir auch ganz egal, denn ich hatte mit seiner Frau überhaupt keine Verbindung. Er war so aktiv mit mir und wollte mir immer eine Freude machen. Ich kriegte zu Weihnachten auch was. Und auf einmal war er tot.
Also war das quasi dein erster Fan oder Verehrer?
Das weiß ich auch nicht.
Oder dein größter damals?
Aber ist das öfter vorgekommen, dass ihr, also wir werden ja dann später noch drüber sprechen, wie das eigentlich kam, dass ihr auch in Süddeutschland gespielt habt. Ist dir das häufig öfter passiert?
Nee. Wohl, dass ich angesprochen wurde, Autogramme geben sollte und so weiter. Wir wurden auch nicht ausgefiffen nach Beendigung des Spiels. Da will ich mich jetzt nicht wichtig tun und das verschönern, was vielleicht gar nicht gewesen ist. Wir haben das gezeigt, was wir ohne großes Trainer-Training gemacht haben, was unser Talent war, was wir ausgeschöpft haben und in dem wir uns auf der Wiese da trainiert haben, kann ich auch Näheres gar nicht mehr dazu sagen, dass wir die Marlborofügel alle plattgetreten haben und statt der Tore haben wir unsere Taschen. Haben wir dahingestellt, zwei, zwei, vier. Und damit haben wir uns zehn Jahre, haben wir uns damit, ja wie soll ich mich sagen, unser Talent trainiert. Und ganz zum Schluss, ein Handballverein in Erx oder Felix, ich weiß es nicht mehr, da konnten wir Fußball spielen.
Da durften wir auch auf Tore.
Aber, das war zur Winterzeit, da war es um fünf Uhr schon dunkel. Wir waren alle, standen wir im Beruf, hatten unterschiedliche Dienste. Das war nicht das Ideale, obwohl es ideal war, so ihr könnt hier Fußball spielen, ja. Da habt ihr zwei Tore und so. Das wäre ein wunderbares Geschenk gewesen, was wir hätten Jahre vorher schon gerne gehabt. Aber dadurch, dass wir alle im Beruf standen, war das so unterschiedlich. Viele waren Verkäuferinnen, die hatten bis halb sieben, da musste sie putzen, bis sie dann soweit waren. Wann war es vielleicht halb acht? Ich weiß es nicht. Alles zu spät.
Ja, man muss eben dazu sagen, also der DFB hatte innerhalb seiner Strukturen den Frauenfußball verboten und damit auch allen Vereinen, zum Beispiel, die einen Platz zur Verfügung gestellt hätten, den wäre der sogenannte Sportgroschen entzogen worden. Und der war damals wichtig zur Finanzierung der Vereine. Und auch Schiedsrichter durften solche Spiele nicht pfeifen.
Auch nicht. Die hätten sofort die Kündigung bekommen vom DFB. Aber so, was in meinem Kopf noch haften geblieben ist, als 1970 das Verbot aufgehoben wurde, da haben die Herren gedacht, ach, der Druck von den Mädchen, der wird immer größer, immer größer, größer. Und da haben die sich vielleicht gedacht, Mensch, das müssen wir das Verbot aber aufheben. Dann haben die das wirklich aufgehoben, 1970 vielleicht mit dem Hintergedanken, ach, wir gründen da die Vereine. Und dann wollen wir mal gucken, was passiert, ob die Mädchen überhaupt Lust haben und so weiter und so fort. Ich weiß nicht, was die für Gedankengänge im Kopf hatten, uns das mies zu machen mit der Hoffnung. Das schläft irgendwann bei den Mädchen mal ein. Das war die Resonanz, die ich noch in meinem Kopf habe. Aber im Gegenteil, es wurde immer besser. Und das freut mich. Und deshalb, was ich vorhin sagte, ich möchte jetzt Fußball spielen.
Jetzt in der aktuellen Zeit wärst du gerne da.
Aber weißt du was?
Wir könnten uns nicht schneller rechts außen gebrochen.
Ja, ja, ja, da wäre ich auch gerne dabei. Aber ach, das sind so Gedanken, weißt du. Jeder Mensch hat Gedanken, die weg sind, du. Die kann er nicht in die Tat umsetzen. Es war schön. Ich kann nur eins sagen. Es waren die zehn schönsten Jahre meines Lebens. So weiter.
Dann erzähl mir davon noch ein bisschen mehr. Wie lief denn das zum Beispiel damals, als ihr dann Plätze suchen musstet? Ich habe in einem Interview gelesen, dass ihr quasi mit der Straßenbahn gefahren seid und Ausschau gehalten habt, auf welcher Wiese man jetzt spielen könnte.
Ja, so war das. Wir hatten ja gar keinen Fußballplatz. Wir hatten ja das Verbot. Die Vereine, die wollten uns keinen Fußballplatz als Trainingsplatz geben. Das haben wir nicht geschafft. Oder, ich weiß es nicht, wir haben uns nicht so intensiv darum bemüht. Ich weiß es nicht, also da muss ich mich bedeckt halten. Ich weiß nur, wir sind selbst...
Auf jeden Fall wurde es euch nicht leicht gemacht.
Ja, nein, es wurde uns nicht leicht gemacht. Im Gegenteil, man versuchte immer wieder, es uns schwer zu machen. Aber wir waren so gallig und so freudig erregt, endlich gibt es Mädchenfußball. Und da sind wir eingestiegen und hatten unsere Freude. Und das waren, wie ich vorhin schon sagte, die zehn schönsten Jahre meines Lebens. Das ist nicht gelogen, das stimmt.
Ich habe gelesen, dass es Ende der 60er Jahre um die 600 bis 1000 Vereine sprechen, manche Quellen sogar davon, schon gab es nur von und für Mädchen. Und obwohl es das Verbot seit Mitte der 50er gab, wurde erst dann 70 aufgehoben. Kannst du mir was dazu erzählen, wie es überhaupt dazu kam, dass es mit Grün-Weiß-Dortmund und Fortuna-Dortmund zwei Vereine sogar in Dortmund gab?
Ja, also wir Fortuna-Dortmund, wo ich dann gewechselt, gewechselt habe. Wir waren sehr, sehr stark. Wir waren vom Talent her, waren viele, viele dabei, die talentiert waren. Aber Grün-Weiß ist nachher verschwunden.
Aber weißt du, wer die Vereine gegründet hat?
Ja, meine Freundin Anne Droste, die vor zwei Jahren gestorben ist, die war mit als Gründungsmitglied. Das war auch eine gute Fußballspielerin. Die hat rechte Läuferin gespielt, die war talentiert und hat die Christa auf eine Reise geschickt. Die war ja schnell, ich rechte von der wunderbaren Pässe. Dann ging es los. Das hat mich auch was gekostet, als sie tot war. Sie ist, Moment, ich werde jetzt 88, vor zwei Jahren war das, dann muss sie so 86 gewesen sein. Ich war in der Sterbestunde bei ihr. Ich habe gesehen, wie sie in den Tod geschlafen ist. Ich habe gesehen, wie sie gekämpft hat, um zu leben oder was auch immer. Ich habe sie angesprochen. Keine Reaktion. Auf einmal riss sie die Augen auf. Ganz weit auf, so vielleicht für zwei, drei Sekunden. Dann hat sie sie geschlossen und es dauerte nicht lange. War sie tot. Das war ein lieber guter Mensch. Wir haben uns wirklich gut verstanden. Und die Freundschaft hat auch lange, lange gedauert. Es gibt so Menschen, da kann man sich anklammern, weil man der Meinung ist, die passt zu dir. Die tickt so wie du. Ich meine, das können sie als Mann auch sagen, wenn sie einen Freund kennen, mit dem sie sich gut verstehen, dann sind sie vielleicht auch meiner Meinung. Naja, aber so. Und dann, ja, entwickelte sich das alles positiv. Ja, und ich habe ja dann, ich glaube 1975 habe ich mit dem Handball-Sport aufgehört, UT Gewitten. Ich hatte dann erst in Löhnen gespielt, da hatte man mich rübergeholt. Dann habe ich da auch im Tor gespielt, war gut im Tor. Dann kam UT Gewitten und hat mich gelotst. Ich soll doch bei ihnen spielen, die spielten eine Klasse höher. Dann haben wir das so weit geschafft, dass wir ein Jahr Bundesliga im Handball-Sport noch hatten. Ja, das waren auch zehn schöne Jahre. Und dann habe ich aber, ich weiß aber auch jetzt gar nicht, warum ich aufgehört habe, Fußball zu spielen. Jetzt gehen wir mal vom Jahrgang aus. 37 geboren, von 65 bis 75. Wie viel sind das?
Nochmal zehn Jahre und sie waren dann 38.
Genau, ich glaube wegen des Alters. Dann weißt du, man will ja immer noch Leistung zeigen. Du merkst ja selber an dir, oh, der hätte es aber halten können, weißt du. Das sind auch so, wo man in mich geht, in sich geht und überlegt, hast du das Tor in Schuld? Ja, wie gesagt, ich habe dann im Tor gespielt, ich war ein guter Torwart. Also Handball wäre nicht mein Ding gewesen.
Und warum wollten Sie damals da nicht zurück in den Fußball? Also Sie sind 1965, haben Sie Ihr letztes Spiel für Fortuna Dortmund gemacht?
Ja, richtig.
Und haben dann noch bis 1975 Handball gespielt? Das heißt, Sie hätten quasi nach dem Aufhebung des Verbots ja durchaus versuchen können, wieder zurück in den Fußball zu kommen?
Nee, aber man wurde älter und so weiter. Und je älter man wird, umso mehr verliert man sein Talent, seine Schnelligkeit, all das, was so in den Jahren kommt, wenn man älter wird. Das habe ich schon begriffen. Und da bin ich zum Kegelsport drüber getreten. Und ich weiß nicht, zwei oder dreimal sind wir Deutscher Mannschaftsmeister geworden.
Sagen Sie mal, Sie haben ja immer, also zwei Dinge.
Jetzt sagst du wieder Sie zu mir.
Stimmt, du, Entschuldigung. Macht nichts, hau rein. Also, zwei Dinge fallen mir an dir auf. Das eine ist, dass du in allen Sportarten Erfolg hattest. Das haben wir jetzt gar nicht besprochen. Bevor du Fußball gespielt hast, Leichtathletik gemacht und bist westdeutsche Meisterin in der 4x100-Meter-Staffel geworden.
Richtig.
Dann hast du Fußball gespielt, da müssen wir gleich noch länger drüber reden, weil du hast ja auch Länderspiele gemacht in zigfacher Anzahl. Also so schlecht kannst du auch nicht gewesen sein. Und dann hast du mir jetzt erzählt, Handball, es ging bis zur Bundesliga. Und jetzt sagst du mir noch, dass du auch Kegelmeisterin geworden bist. Also das eine ist, du hast immer sehr viel Erfolg gehabt. Und mich würde interessieren, welche Rückmeldung hast du auf diesen Erfolg bekommen von deiner Umgebung? Und das zweite ist, kann es sein, dass du sehr, sehr ehrgeizig bist. Und deswegen dann auch vielleicht ein bisschen streng mit dir warst und gesagt hast, na, das reicht jetzt nicht mehr fürs höchste Niveau. Und dann will ich gar nicht nochmal.
Was du jetzt als letzten Satz gegeben hast, das stimmt, ja. Man will ja dann auch, wenn man weiß, du warst wirklich klasse. Du warst schnell, du warst talentiert. All das hast du ausgeschöpft, was ich auch getan habe. Zehn Jahre bei Fortuna Dortmund, zehn Jahre bei UT Gewitten und so weiter. Und nachher, wenn man älter wird, dann merkst du ja auch an deinem Körper, Mensch, irgendetwas stimmt nicht. Deswegen ist alt und was passiert mit dir, ja. So ist das gewesen. Und dann warst du. Man muss Lust haben. Und wenn du Lust hast und hast Talent, dann kannst du was bringen. Das war damals auch bei mir so.
Und hast du darauf auch positive Rückmeldungen bekommen? Weil das sind ja beachtliche Erfolge. Und man muss jetzt nicht immer diese Frau-Mann-Schiene fahren. Aber ich denke, es ist ein Fakt, dass wenn du ein Mann wärst mit diesen Erfolgen, dann wären über dich schon Bücher erschienen, Filme. Du wärst noch früher in die Hall of Fame des deutschen Sports aufgenommen worden, in der du jetzt allerdings auch bist. Das ist ja sehr wahrscheinlich so.
Ich kann mich ein Folgendes erinnern. Das war 1957 im Dante-Stadion München. Da haben wir gegen die Holländerin gespielt. Die meisten Spiele, Länderspiele, die wir gemacht haben, waren gegen die Holländerin. Ja, die waren eigentlich sehr angenehm. Sie waren eigentlich so gut wie wir. Aber meistens haben wir sie weggefegt.
Sie waren doch nicht eigentlich so gut wie ihr. Woher kommt das, dass das vor allem die Niederlande waren, gegen die man gespielt hat?
Ich weiß nicht. Das Fußballverbot für Mädchen, Frauen, das war schon so verteilt hier in Europa. Ich habe mich nie darum gekümmert. Ich habe nur gehört, die dürfen nicht. Österreich war genau das Gleiche, obwohl wir eine Woche in Österreich gespielt haben. Der Rundfunk oder das Fernsehen, weiß ich nicht, hat mich aus dem Bett geholt, aus dem Hotel. Das war ganz früh morgens. Da musste ich mit dem Mann ins Studio gehen. Dann hat er mich ausgequetscht. Das war in Wien, das war auch was Neues, dass mich da jemand aus dem Bett holt, wollte ein Interview mit mir machen. Ja, da fing das alles so langsam an, weißt du? Ja, und daher war ich alt und dann habe ich gedacht, nee, jetzt hörst du auf, du bringst nicht mehr das, was du gerne gebracht hast. Und man muss ja auch dann in sich gehen und nicht blöd dann da her spielen. Nee, wäre nicht mein Ding gewesen. Ich war immer ausgefüllt. Zehn Jahre Fußball, zehn Jahre Handball. Und dann nachher, ich weiß nicht, wie lange, mit dem Kegelsport, das war wieder eine ganz andere Zeit. Kann man nicht mit den Bällen, also mit Fußball und Handball vergleichen, aber es waren auch liebe nette Menschen, das kann man nicht anders negativ ausdrücken. Nein, nein, wir waren alle sehr, sehr lieb, aber wir waren ja dann auch schon Ende weg von der Jugend. Ich weiß es jetzt nicht. Kann ich mich jetzt nicht festlegen, wie alt ich war? Aber jetzt gehen wir mal nur von, was habe ich gesagt, 55, 65, 75, wo ich mit dem Handball aufgehört habe. 75, 38, geboren 37 Jahre, hast du vorhin gesagt, oder?
Ja, 38 Jahre.
Ja, ja, genau. Ja, dann fängst du an, alt zu werden. Du, wenn du nicht aufpasst, bist du eine alte Frau. Nee, nee, war nichts für mich.
Aber erzähl mir mal, mich würde noch deine Anfänge im Fußball interessieren, weil du hast, du hast Leichtklätig gemacht. Das habe ich jetzt gerade eben schon erwähnt. Und dann bist du eben zu Fortuna Dortmund und durftest dort Fußball spielen. Wie war denn das? Also was zum Beispiel Schuhe angeht, mit welchen Schuhen hast du damals gespielt? Woher hat man dann irgendwann vielleicht auch mal Trikots bekommen? Wie habt ihr das alles organisiert und wer hat das organisiert?
So, das ist ein Thema. Wir hatten hier alle wenig verdient. Viele waren in der Lehre, haben 45 D-Mark verdient pro Monat und so weiter. Ich weiß nicht, wie das Elternhaus tickte, aber Geld hatten wir alle nicht. Wir waren alle so bodenständig, natürlich, mit wenig Geld. Dann mussten wir natürlich Trikot haben. Dann haben wir das, entweder haben wir das mit einer D-Mark oder mit zwei D-Mark, haben wir das Trikot bezahlt im Sportgeschäft. Wir hatten nicht Geld, um das Saba hinzulegen. Da hatte sich keiner herausgestellt und hat gesagt, du, ich bezahle aber jetzt mein Trikot selber. Nein, wir haben alle, haben wir das alles so gemacht. Das Gleiche war mit Fußballschuhen das Gleiche, ja. Ja, Gott, ja, ja.
Hattest du gleich Fußballschuhe, als du losgelegt hast?
Da hatte ich welche, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie ich da drangekommen bin. Habe ich die von meinen Eltern bekommen oder habe ich die auch aufgestottert? Da habe ich jetzt keine Meinung. Das ist weg, das weiß ich nicht mehr. Das kann ich nicht beantworten.
Und dann sah damals aber ein Tag für dich so aus, also du hast dann deine Lehre gemacht bei der Post und nach Feierabend hast du deine Fußballschuhe in die Hand genommen, hast dich in die Straßenbahn gesetzt und ihr habt euch eine Wiese gesucht zum Spielen. Oder wie habt ihr euch organisiert?
Ne, das kann ich auch nicht dazu sagen. Ja, weil ich hatte unregelmäßigen Dienst, sagte ich ja vorhin schon mal. Ich habe auch manchmal bis 23 Uhr arbeiten müssen, von 3 Uhr an oder von manchmal bis 22 Uhr. Oder samstags oder sonntags kam auch noch dahin zu. Was soll ich dazu sagen? Wir haben das alles akzeptiert. Das war unser Beruf. Dann konnte ich nach fünf Jahren meine Beamtenprüfung machen. Ja, gut und schön bestanden. Ja, und dann ging so die Entwicklung, dass du immer irgendwann durch was auch, jeder dem, was du für eine Arbeit gemacht hast, wurdest du dann eine Etage höher. Erst warst du Sekretärin, dann warst du Obersekretärin, dann warst du Hauptsekretärin. Ich bin als Hauptsekretärin, habe ich dann später aufgehört. Oder ich hätte noch die Inspektorenlaufbahn einschlagen müssen. Da hatte ich keinen Bock zu. Das wollte ich nicht mehr. Ich kam mit dem Geld aus, was ich verdient hatte und war damit glücklich. Warum soll ich mich dann noch mal quälen müssen für die Inspektorenlaufbahn? Je nachdem, wie da die Prüfung ist. Das habe ich nicht mehr mitgemacht.
Aber stimmt es, dass die Verbeamtung bei dir nach hinten verschoben wurde, weil du wegen des Fußballs verfehlt hast?
Das hat mich maßlos geärgert. Ich hörte dann auch, wir saßen da alle, waren am Arbeiten. Da wurden einige rausgeholt. Mensch, die haben doch mit dir die Prüfung gemacht. Jetzt bin ich zur Aufsicht gegangen. Wir hatten ja immer eine Aufsicht da. Ich so, was ist denn da los? Die müssen jetzt, ich weiß gar nicht wohin. Ich so, warum bin ich denn nicht dabei? Ja, sie sind diesmal nicht dabei. Sie sind beim nächsten Mal dabei. Warum? Sie haben Fußball gespielt.
Also war es der Fußball, nicht die Fehtage, sondern dass du...
Ja, das waren ja dann, ich weiß nicht, was die da zusammengeklamüsert haben, um mich da abzustellen für irgendwann, wenn die nächste Besoldung kommt, dass sie dich dann da reinschieben. Das haben sie ja dann auch gemacht. Das hat mich maßlos geärgert. Ich hab doch keinen beschissen. Ich muss mal diesen Ausdruck jetzt sagen. Ich hab das so empfunden. Warum macht man das mit dir? Du warst doch ehrlich. Du hast dir doch nichts schenken lassen. Ja, du hast zwar zehn D-Mark für die Bereitstellung, dass sie deinen Dienst übernimmt. Du revansierst dich und übernimmst dann. Es war ja jetzt nur die Gefälligkeit, dass ich jemanden hatte, der mir geholfen hat. Dann war ich halt nicht da. Ich weiß ja nicht, was die Obersten dafür vermerken machten. Das hat mich gar nicht interessiert. Hauptsache, es kommt Fußballspiel. Das war das, was mich glücklich machte, wo ich Glanz in den Augen hatte.
Jetzt noch kann ich den Hörerinnen und Hörern sagen. Und wie war das dann? Wie habt ihr denn dann Spiele organisiert? Weil es gab ja dann so verschiedene Spiele. Also zum einen gegen andere Teams aus anderen Städten. Aber eben dann auch irgendwann, das musst du mir auf jeden Fall alles auch nochmal erklären, eben auch als Nationalteam auf richtigen Reisen. Also daher kommt es ja, dass du zum Beispiel so viel in Süddeutschland warst. Aber jetzt lass mal erstmal mit den Spielen hier im Ruhrgebiet zum Beispiel begangen.
Das war ganz schlecht. Im Ruhrgebiet waren mehrere Vereine. Ich weiß aber auch gar nicht, wie lange konnten die überhaupt Fußball spielen? Auf einmal waren sie weg. Es war in Essen, in Oberhausen, ich glaube in Essen zwei Vereine, in Oberhausen, in Duisburg. Ich war erstaunt, dass plötzlich Frauenfußball in diesem Verein war. Aber die waren nicht lebhaft. Was da jetzt passiert ist, das weiß ich nicht. Hat mich auch gar nicht interessiert. Mein Fußball hat mich interessiert. Wenn die anderen kaputt gingen, das hat mich nicht gestört. Wir hatten immer, das machte der Herr Floritz aus München, der hatte die ganzen Fußballspiele aus kommunalen Städten in Süddeutschland. Was haben wir da Süddeutschland bereits, das kann ich gar nicht aufzählen. Man kann sagen, erst mal in den Hauptstädten oder in großen Städten usw. Und wir waren so beliebt. Ich habe es persönlich gehört, dass man sagte, ihr habt so wunderbar Fußball gespielt, wann kommt ihr denn wieder? Es war nicht nur einmal diese Aussage, die ist an mich gerichtet gewesen und ich sollte mich dazu äußern. Was ich gesagt habe, weiß ich auch nicht mehr. Aber das weiß ich, dass ich da gefragt worden bin und so weiter. Und dann habe ich auch geantwortet. Richtig, natürlich geantwortet. Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich möchte, denke ich mal, dass ich das gesagt habe. Ich denke mal, wir kommen noch mal wieder. Und da muss ich dran denken an die schöne Zeit in Würzburg. Zwei oder drei Mal haben wir da gespielt, wo der alte Apotheker noch an mich herangetreten ist. Der war so freundlich, der alte Mann. Und was ich alles vorhin schon erzählte, dass er mir diese Pakete zuschickte. Und Boxbeutel hat er auch noch Pakete geschickt. Das war ein toller Typ und dann war er tot. Das hat mich auch irgendwie beeindruckt, so negativ beeindruckt. Aber wie ich vorhin schon sagte, mit seiner Frau hatte ich gar keine Verbindung. Er hat alles an sich gerissen. Er wollte mit mir korrespondieren, hat das auch geschafft. Und es war alles eine wunderschöne Zeit mit ihm.
Aber dieser Josef Floritz, der euch die Spiele organisiert hat. Ich habe später auch noch von dem Willi Ruppert gelesen.
Hör auf, ich entschuldige mal, mach den Satz zu Ende, den du sagen willst. Ich werde da gleich was zu sagen.
Mich würde nämlich die Rolle dieser beiden Männer interessieren, weil, so wie ich es verstanden habe, hat es diese Männer gebraucht, um Spiele zu organisieren, um auch die inoffiziellen National-Länderspiele zu organisieren. Aber ich habe mich gefragt, aus welchen Motiven heraus die das gemacht haben.
Ich weiß nur aus dem Motiv heraus von dem Floris aus München. Der war menschlich so lieb und nett. Der hat alles für uns getan. Wir haben uns nie beschwert, dass uns etwas nicht gefallen hat. Der hat uns schöne Hotels besorgt. Der war freundlich. Der hat auch abends, dass wir schön zusammengesessen haben. Das war alles eine wunderbare Zeit. Parallel lief die Zeit mit dem Ruppert. Ich bin froh, dass ich da nie reingeraten bin. Der Kerl wollte nur Geld schöpfen. Da hat er, glaube ich, in Berlin auch gespielt.
Ja, der hat die inoffizielle EM da.
Irgendetwas hat der.
Er hat es mit dem Geld davon gerannt.
Dann ist er aber, glaube ich, abgesackt. Wie weiß ich gar nicht, was da passiert ist. Ich bin froh, dass er weg war. Denn der hätte uns alles versaut. Wir waren ja jetzt gerade dabei, uns gut zu gestalten, gut Fußball zu spielen. Und dann kommt der Ruppert und macht so eine Kacke dann da, ja. Nee, nee, nee, ich war froh, nicht, dass er tot war, aber dass er das nicht geschafft hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Vereine, die mit ihm gezogen sind, ob die das alles so mitgemacht haben, ohne zu meckern. Ich habe keine Meinung dazu. Ich habe auch niemanden gefragt. Das interessierte mich nicht. Mich interessierte, was der Floritz machte. Und wir waren alle jahrelang, der hat uns auch, ich glaube, wir haben auch einmal in der Schweiz gespielt, meine ich. Oder in Österreich, das hat er auch gemacht, die eine Woche, dass wir da zu Gast sein konnten und haben gegen die Österreicherinnen gespielt. Aber die waren, vom Talent her, waren die nicht so gut.
Die habt ihr auch weggefegt, das habe ich gesehen.
Ich weiß nicht, 10 oder 11. Ich weiß es nicht. Aber wir waren froh, dass wir mal raus konnten, ja.
Aber als welches Team wart ihr dann quasi dort vor Ort? Also der Herr Floritz, der hat irgendwie den Kontakt zu euch bekommen und hat euch dann diese Spiele organisiert. Waren das dann in Anführungszeichen Länderspielen, weil ihr als deutsches Nationalteam dorthin seid?
Ja, das waren die Länderspiele. Ja, denn wir konnten aus dem südtotschen Raum, aus Nürnberg waren da, glaube ich, zwei Frauen. Ich weiß nicht, Menschenskind noch mal. Das ist alles schon so lange her, weißt du, wo man gar nicht mehr sich erinnern möchte, was damals gewesen ist, obwohl das eigentlich auch für das, was man erlebt hat, auch wichtig ist. Ich weiß nur, dass die mich aus Nürnberg, dass die mir einen Brief geschickt hat und wollte mit mir korrespondieren und so. Und sie würde sich freuen, wenn wir uns mal wiedersehen würden, aber wir haben uns nicht wieder gesehen. Dann ist der Floris gestorben, 65 Jahre aufgehört, ich weiß nicht, 64 oder was. Seine Frau hat noch zwei Spiele gemacht, die er beschlossen hatte und dann war es aus bei uns. Viele aus unserer Mannschaft haben geheiratet, wo der Mann was dagegen hatte und wir hatten ja eben keinen Nachwuchs. Wir konnten nicht in die Mannschaft steigen und sagen, so jetzt spielst du Fußball und so weiter. Das war nicht. Das war das Verbot der Eltern, die sich durchgesetzt hatten und so weiter. Dann haben die Mädchen, die haben sich nicht gewehrt oder was, haben gesagt, ich will jetzt Fußball spielen oder was. Ich weiß es nicht, wie das Elternhaus bei denen war. Ich kann nur das sagen, was ich erlebt habe. Und wir maßlos enttäuscht waren, als wir zum Notar gegangen sind und haben uns löschen lassen. Wir waren nicht mehr bestückt mit elf Mädchen. Viele geheiratet, wo der Mann sagte, du spielst kein Fußball. Und die Frau sekundär war.
Da hast du ja auch eine persönliche Erfahrung gemacht, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Natürlich habe ich da. Da fangen sie alle an zu lachen. Das habe ich auch gestern erzählt. Das ergab sich so, weil ich war voll drin im Interview, positiv, alles so. Und dann habe ich gedacht, ja gut und schön. Viele haben von uns geheiratet. Ich habe auch geheiratet. Vorher war alles gut und schön. Er war damit einverstanden, dass Christa Fußball spielte. Und dann haben wir geheiratet. Und dann hat er gesagt, du spielst kein Fußball mehr. Ja, da hat er was gesagt. Das Schönste war, was ich küsse, je gewünscht hat, Fußball zu spielen. Und das, das, das wird er dir verbieten. Dann haben wir uns herumgezankt. Und so habe ich gedacht, das brauchst du nicht. Du willst weiter Fußball spielen. Hab ich auch gemacht. Er ist zu Hause geblieben. Manchmal ist er auch mitgefahren. Aber der war irgendwie, was soll ich sagen? Ich will nicht negativ über ihn sprechen. Er war sehr lieb zu mir. Das kann man nicht anders sagen. Aber er kriegte keinen Anschluss mit unserer Mannschaft. Was er sich dabei gedacht hat, weiß ich nicht. Will ich auch nicht wissen. Dann ist er auch schon mal ein paar Mal mitgefahren. Das konnte ich ihm nicht verbieten. Wenn er frei hatte, er war bei der Bahn beschäftigt. Ich glaube, er hatte nachher auch sein Beamtenverhältnis. Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau. Ja, gut. Dann habe ich gesagt, dann lassen wir uns scheiden. Gut, ich, mein Vater wollte mit mir gehen. Ich hin zum Gericht. Ich gehe dann den Gang entlang. Guck, links. Da sitzt ja der Uli da mit seinem Papa. Ich habe gegrüßt, ich habe keine Antwort gekriegt. Na ja, gut und schön. Dann wurde ich schuldig geschieden. Damals gab es Schuld oder Unschuld. Das war mir auch scheißegal. Ich war frei. Jetzt konnte ich Fußball spielen, so wie ich wollte, aber alles ging dem Ende so zu, ja. Ja, das war die Zeit.
Ich habe gelesen und es gibt jetzt auch zum Beispiel einen Podcast, da kommt Bärbel-Wohlleben drin vor und für die war die WM 1954, die Männer-WM, ein sehr wichtiges Ereignis. Ich habe gelesen vereinzelt, dass das bei dir auch so war. Allerdings, wenn wir jetzt so sprechen, habe ich das Gefühl, du hast dich auch schon vorher für Fußball sehr begeistert.
1954 bin ich noch leicht athleticsch gemacht. Da war die WM ja. Da bin ich noch mit einem jungen Mann. Wir waren so in einem Alter bei OSV Hörde. Du, da wird gleich das Fußballspiel übertragen. Ja, wo gehen wir denn dahin? Ja, da sagt er, warte mal ab, da ist ein Friseurladen in Hörde. Der hat im Fenster, hat der, hat der sein Fernseher entstehen.
Ja, super.
Dann haben wir beiden dahingetickt, haben uns vor die Scheibe gestellt, dann kamen immer so hin und wieder so ein paar Leute dazu. Dann haben wir da das Fußballspiel durch die Scheibe gesehen, ja. Zu Hause hatten wir keinen Fernseher, ja. Ja, ich sag ja, ich, das war eine schöne Zeit.
Aber gab es da dann zum Beispiel einen Spieler, wo du dir gedacht hast, das kann ich auch oder ich würde gerne so spielen wie der?
Ah, weißt du was? Ich wurde immer mit dem Helmut Rahn verglichen. Wer auf die Idee gekommen ist, der war natürlich auch rechtsaußen.
Der war aber nicht so schnell wie du, also Entschuldigung.
Ich weiß es nicht, die Männer sind schneller als Frauen, das ist nur mal naturbedingt so, ja. Aber er wurde auch so hervorgehoben als rechtsaußen. Und als ich in München dann mein gutes Spiel gab, machte bei dem 4-2-Sieg, machte ich zwei Tore. Und Gott, oh Gott, war die Christa auf einmal oben drauf.
Das war 57 gegen die Niederlande, das zweite ländliche.
Ja, es war... Weißt du was? Ich habe das Talent gehabt, ich habe das voll ausgenutzt. Und sonst wäre ich jetzt nicht bei dir im Gespräch. Du, das war alles wunderschön.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das jetzt der Höhepunkt sein sollte. Aber, also du hast das WM-Finale damals gesehen und kurz danach ging es ja dann auch los. 55 dann, Grün-Weiß Dortmund, Fortuna Dortmund. Was ich mich gefragt habe, wie lief denn dann eigentlich so ein Training im Park oder auf welchem Platz ihr auch immer gespielt habt?
Ach, weißt du was? Wir hatten einen Trainer, der hätte gerne mit uns trainiert. Der hat das auch ein paar Mal gemacht, aber dann hat er einen Ehekrach gehabt zu Hause. Da hat sich die Frau darüber beschwert. Die war eifersüchtig, dass er mit jungen Mädchen da trainierte. Pups, da war der Kerl nicht mehr da. Dann habe ich das an mich gerissen worden und habe so was, was ich aus der Leichtathletik hatte. Dann haben wir Leichtathletik gemacht, sind gelaufen und so weiter. So, weißt du, damit man was für die Kondition machen konnte. Ja, was sollte ich denn da noch machen auf der Wiese? Wir haben dann einfach Fußball gespielt. Jedes Mal. Wir haben nicht extra was herausgezogen. Jetzt machen wir das und das, du spielst gegen den und so.
Und wie habt ihr die Position geklärt zum Beispiel?
Du, da kann ich dir gar keine Antwort geben. Ich weiß es nicht. Das ist auch weg aus meinem Kopf. Ich weiß es nicht, ob jeder gefragt wurde, wenn mal was möchtest du spielen und so weiter. Oder was spielst du in deinem Verein? Was hast du gesagt und so? Ich weiß auch nicht, was ich gesagt habe. Das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Das Ergebnis war rechts außen. Und dann habt ihr eben Spiele gemacht und vor allem eben diese Spiele tun. Und ihr habt dann eben als deutsche Nationalteam gespielt. Natürlich nicht das offizielle vom DFB anerkannte. Klar, das ging ja noch gar nicht. Bis 1970 nicht. Und erst dann haben sie ja auch noch lange gebraucht. Und diese Spiele, die dann vor allem der Herr Floritz für euch organisiert hat, das waren ja dann mehrere an einem Wochenende. Ihr habt bis zu vier Mal gespielt. Zwei Mal.
Samstags und Sonntags haben wir gespielt.
Und so bist du auf insgesamt 150 Länderspiele gekommen. Es sind ja irre viele Wochen.
Zehn Jahre. Wir haben eigentlich im Sommer früher nicht gespielt. Ich glaube, warte mal, nee, ich muss mich anders ausdrücken. Wir haben im Sommer gespielt. Und dann war das bis Anfang November. Dann kam die Winzerzeit und dann fing das wieder so im März an. So summierten sich der 150 Spiele. Ja, du, jetzt muss ich mir auch noch...
Soll ich dir was holen?
Ja, pass mal auf. Also, Prost, was?
Ja, tschüss. Auf den Herrn Floritz.
Ja, mein lieber Kerl, der hat uns eigentlich verwöhnt und wir können nichts Negatives sagen. Er hat ja auch gegen den DFB gekämpft. Sonst hätte er auf kommunalen Plätzen, die erlaubt ist, gar nicht gekämpft.
Der DFB hat damals Städten, die euch haben spielen lassen, geschrieben, dass sie jetzt keine Länderspiele mehr bekommen, wenn das noch mal vorkommt. Also Steine wurden euch in den Weg gelegt, noch und nöcher.
Und Bestrafung. Ja. Und Bestrafung. Wie, weiß ich nicht, was die Kerle sich da ausgedacht haben im DFB. Weiß ich nicht, ja. Hat uns auch nicht interessiert, uns hat nur interessiert, wir spielen Fußball. Das war unser Lebenswichtiges. Lass mich das ruhig sagen. Aber es war die Zeit so.
Und wie lief dann so eine Woche ab? Also du hast gearbeitet von Montag bis Freitag im Amt dann bei der Post. Musstest manchmal Urlaub einreichen. Ich habe gelesen, es sollen sehr viele Omas gestorben sein, immer wieder und wieder.
Ja, aber die nie gelebt haben.
Genau. So habt ihr euch quasi die Freitage so hingekriegt.
Das hat doch keiner kontrolliert. Hauptsache, es war was Schriftliches da. Oma ist gestorben. Das war meine Freundin Anne, die jetzt vor zwei, nein, oder vor einem Jahr, ich weiß es nicht, muss man nachschauen, gestorben ist. Die hat das gemacht.
Sie hat einfach immer wieder ihre Oma sterben lassen, um Tag freizukriegen.
Du kannst doch nicht schon wieder die Oma sterben lassen. Ich weiß nicht, was dir da noch eingefallen ist. Oder bei den anderen. Das ist gegangen. Keiner hat die Kündigung gekriegt. Siehst du, das ist halt die Zeit gewesen, wo der Mensch nicht so war, wie er heute ist.
Na ja, bzw. eure Arbeit wurde gebraucht. Damals ganz viel des sogenannten Wirtschaftswunders ist ja von Frauen umgesetzt worden. Aber das heißt, ihr seid dann am Freitag mit dem Zug nämlich an nach Süddeutschland gefahren? Nein.
Wie ist so eine Fahrt? Wir sind nicht, ganz selten mit dem Zug. Kann ich mich nicht erinnern. Nee, wüsste ich auch nicht. Wir sind hier in Dortmund, haben einen Bus gemietet bis Oberhausen. Oberhausen stand der Bus schon. Der hat dann auch noch die Holländerin mit hineingenommen. Und wir auch.
Und jetzt seid ihr zusammen in einem Bus runtergefahren.
Mit einem Bus nach Süddeutschland.
Ach, wie war das so?
Wunderbar. Man hat nur so nebensächlich mal mit jemandem gesprochen, aber ansonsten war immer so die Scheidewand so. Wir Deutsche, wir Holländer.
Obwohl ihr so oft gegeneinander gespielt habt, haben sich da keine Freundschaften entwickelt.
Doch, da haben sich Freundschaften entwickelt. Ich glaube, die Greta-Eis-Leben, mit der ich mich da jetzt gezankt habe, die hatte eine Brieffreundschaft über den Fußball. Vor ein paar Wochen ist sie an Krebs gestorben. Sie ist auch öfter dahingefahren, hat sie besucht. Sie war auch schon ein paar Mal hier in Schwerte, wo die Eisleben wohnt. Und dann habe ich auch eine Einladung bekommen. Du komm doch mal vorbei, die, glaube ich, Ria ist die Ria, glaube ich. Die ist da. Ja, ist halt gut. Machen wir mal. Ach, das sind alles so Nebensächlichkeiten.
Aber das heißt also, ihr sitzt ab Oberhausen in diesem Bus, links das deutsche Team, rechts das holländische Team oder auch umgedreht. Und dann fahrt ihr, ja, lasst doch zum Beispiel dann dieses Spiel in München nehmen. 1957.
Moment, ich glaube, da sind wir hingeflogen. Oh, ich meine von Stuttgart. Aber wie komme ich jetzt? Ich weiß von Stuttgart nach München. Aber ich weiß nicht, was war in Stuttgart, ob wir da gespielt haben. Aber warum? Was sollte ich dann in Stuttgart oder wir in Stuttgart? Da muss man wieder trinken.
Ja, trinken in Ruhe was, ne? Waren es nicht manchmal auch zwei Städte an einem Wochenende? Weil ich habe in einem Text gelesen, aber es gibt eben leider sehr wenig über die Zeit, dass es auch den Fall gab, dass ihr Vormittags- und Nachmittagsspielen gespielt habt.
Zwei Spiele an einem Tag? Nein.
Das habt ihr nicht gemacht?
Nein, das hätten wir körperlich auch gar nicht geschafft. Das geht nicht. Du kannst da nicht erscheinen, das Höschen und Trikot an und dann trittst du da vom Ball bis schlapp im zweiten Spiel. Das lächerlich zu machen, wo wir zu kämpfen hatten. Wir wollten durch unser Können, wollten wir uns durchlavieren. Wir haben gekämpft, ja. Und wir hatten auch die Unterstützung von dem Floris, der früher glaube ich selber mal Fußball gespielt hat oder Geschiedsrichter, das weiß ich nicht. Der hat das immer prima gemacht, wie ich vorhin schon sagte, auf kommunalen Plätzen. Da waren wir immer herzlich willkommen. Manchmal war sogar eine Blasmusik da, ja. Und bevor wir einlaufen konnten, mit dem Deutschlandlied oder mit dem holländischen Lied, haben die da erst rumgeholt. Das war alles wunderschön, das passte zu uns. Wir hatten Freude und waren jedes Mal überrascht, wenn da die Musik auflief.
Und wie viele Leute waren da? Also, weil vom Spiel 1957, da ist ja bekannt, dass das richtig richtig viele waren.
18.000 oder wie viel waren da?
Genau, 18.000, sagt man.
Du, es waren immer paar Tausende da, aber München war den meisten. Ich hab in Bremen, da haben wir auch gespielt, aber da war ich nicht dabei, weil ich Urlaub angemeldet hatte und ich wusste, dass über, ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich gebucht habe, ist auch nicht so lebenswichtig. Da musste ich meine Reise antreten nach Süditalien. Na ja, gut und schön. Das habe ich dann wahrgenommen, ich hätte gerne in Bremen gespielt, aber Näheres kann ich dazu nicht sagen.
Aber das heißt, es waren immer ein paar Tausend Zuschauer in jeder Stadt, in der er war. Deswegen hat es sich ja auch für alle gelohnt, diese Spiele zu veranstalten.
Ja, so war das.
Und wie war das Publikum? Du hast mal in einem Interview von Feldstechern erzählt, die manche Männer mitgenommen hätten.
Die waren immer dabei. Feldstecher waren immer dabei und wie ich auch schon öffentlich sagte, was wollen die denn mit Feldstechern? Wollen sie auf deinen Busen gucken oder auf deine Knie oder auf deinen Hintern? Das war meine Äußerung, weil ich wütend war, dass die Feldstecher mitgenommen haben, um uns näher heranzuholen, was sie auch immer damit machten. Es war mir auch egal, nur ich musste meinen blöden Kommentar dazu geben, den ich auch wirklich gegeben habe. Ja, hast du schon gehört?
Aber es waren ja nicht nur Männer oder wie war das Publikum?
Ja, eigentlich durchwachsen. Es war noch, dass die Männer ihre Ehefrauen mitgenommen hatten. Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen plus, minus und so. Ich sag einfach, war gut durchwachsen. Männer und Frauen, aber prozentual kann ich mich da nicht festlegen. Aber ich kann dir nur sagen, wenn du eine gute Leistung gemacht hast, da wurdest du schon während des Spiels applaudiert, habe ich oft gekriegt. Und das gibt dir irgendetwas im Inneren, du und im Kopf, du liebest halt. Was ist das denn jetzt? Du kriegst jetzt schon Applaus, hast ja noch gar kein Tor gemacht. Und wenn ich dein Tor gemacht habe, dann ging es los. Das sind alles so schöne Erinnerungen. Die nimmt dir keiner.
Also war das auch in Summe alles, weil ihr habt natürlich auch leider Beschimpfungen erlebt, Beleidigungen, Leute, die gekommen sind, um sich zu amüsieren. Aber das überwiegt bei weitem nicht so wichtig.
Du, das kann ich dir nicht sagen. Es gibt ja auch Menschen, die, wenn das Spiel schön ist, dass sie trotzdem darum meckern. Ja, aus welchem Grund auch immer, weiß ich nicht. Nein, weißt du was? Das geht uns auch nichts an. Lass die Menschen dann denken, wie sie wollen, nur sie sollen ehrlich bleiben und sollen sich da nicht wichtig durch, indem sie negativ über uns Frauen da schimpfen. Ja, das ist in jeder menschlichen Beziehung so. Das darf nicht sein. Ja, man soll ehrlich sein und sich freuen. Oh Gott, schön, dass die Mädchen Fußball spielen. So haben welche auch gesagt. Ja, man hörte das dann, wenn man angesprochen wurde nach Spielende und so weiter. Die haben sich wirklich gefreut. Die haben einen gedrückt. Und ach Gott, und waren so lieb und nett. Das kann man nicht anders bezeichnen, ob es das heute auch noch ist, glaube ich nicht. Aber die Zeit haben wir auch erlebt. Ja, das war schön.
Ja, das freut mich auch, dass es quasi eine schöne Erinnerung ist und sehr schön, dass wenige Negative dann ja offenbar in der Minderheit war. Und gleichzeitig stelle ich mir das für die Frauen im Publikum ganz besonders vor. Für dich war es etwas Besonderes zu sehen. Es gibt jetzt andere Frauen, die auch Fußball spielen, so wie ich. Und ich kann da in ein Team gehen, in einen Verein gehen. Du hast jetzt vorhin schon erzählt von einer Nürnberger Spielerin, die den Kontakt zu dir gesucht hat. Weißt du, ob das für Inspiration gesorgt hat in den Städten, in denen ihr wart?
Du, dazu kann ich mich gar nicht äußern. Und das ist so, ich glaube, so lange haben wir gar nicht korrespondiert. Die wollte nur etwas von mir wissen, was ich dann auch geschrieben habe und so weiter. Sie wollte mich auch wiedersehen. Ich sollte mal nach Nürnberg kommen und so weiter. Aber du, da hatte ich keinen Bock zu. Erst mal, nee. Da haben wir das anhören. Und dann hätte die mich bestimmt zu dieser Fußballmannschaft nach Nürnberg gebracht. Du, da hatte ich keinen Bock. Ich war noch so beschäftigt, einmal beruflich und dann ja, was man halt so bei Fortuna gemacht hat, ja. Wir haben versucht, oh, da muss ich, das weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, ob wir wirklich geschafft haben, zweimal die Woche trainieren. Ich will mich nicht festlegen. Also einmal ganz bestimmt, ja. Nee, das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, ob wir zweimal trainiert haben. Aber dadurch, dass viele Mädchen auch Verkäuferinnen waren und die nicht um halb sieben Schluss machen durften, weil sie ja noch in der Lehre waren, da mussten sie putzen. Ja, und die Zeit ist denen weggelaufen, ja. Und dann kamen sie in der Dunkelheit an. Wenn überhaupt die Möglichkeit bestand, dass sie dahingebracht wurden. Von uns hatte dann, glaube ich, gar keine Autos oder was. Ja, wir sind hier in den Vororten, wenn wir hier gespielt haben oder trainiert haben. Höschpark ist im Norden von Dortmund, hinter dem Borsigplatz. Haben wir dann da trainiert und der hat uns, dieser Rasen, der hat uns gefestigt bis zum Schluss. Dann mussten wir 65, was ich vorhin schon sagte, aufhören, weil wir keine Elfspielerin mehr zusammenkriegen. Und was ich noch sagte, zu dritt beim Notar gewesen, haben uns streichen lassen und durch die Streichung, dass es uns nicht mehr gab, wofür wir so viele Jahre gekämpft haben, haben wir erst mal geheult, als wir draußen vor der Tür standen. Das war der Schluss von meiner Fußballzeit.
1965 dann. Wie war denn das Verhältnis zu DFB, zur Stadt Dortmund, zu anderen Vereinen?
Da haben wir uns gar nicht drum gekümmert. Der Floris machte das in Süddeutschland. Das hat er immer hingekriegt. Er wird auch vielleicht Ärger gehabt haben, dass man ihn nicht für voll genommen hat oder ihn vielleicht auch rausgeschmissen hat. Weiß ich nicht. Aber wir haben nur Gutes erlebt. Und das hat uns gefreut. Viele von uns sind noch gar nicht in den Urlaub gefahren, weil sie ihr Pinky-Pinky nicht hatten, das Geld nicht hatten. Sie waren in der Lehre. Und je nachdem, was man für Eltern aushat, die konnten vielleicht auch nicht den Urlaub für ihre Tochter bezahlen. Das ist nur meine Vermutung. Ich weiß es nicht. Es war halt so, ja und...
Aber ihr seid so gut rumgekommen.
Wir sind gut rumgekommen. Ja, wir haben viel gesehen. Es war auch so, dass wir, wenn wir Nachmittags gespielt haben, dass der Flugendist jemand beauftragte und hat uns eine Stadtbesichtigung geschenkt. Ja, dann sind wir alle mal los. Und dann hat der uns, so ein Reiseführer, hat er uns durch seine Stadt geführt, was wir immer sehr herzlich aufgenommen hatten. Dass man uns sowas schenkte, ja.
Und jetzt hast du über 150 Länderspiele gemacht. Woher weißt du das? Hast du eine Liste geführt? Und kannst du mir auch sagen, wie viele Tore du geschossen hast?
Nee, das weiß ich nicht.
Schade.
Ich habe viele Tore geschossen. Aber ich weiß auch jetzt gar nicht so, dass mal vor Jahren habe ich mir die Mühe gemacht, habe die Fußballkritiken mal alle so rausgeholt.
Hast du die noch?
Ach nee, habe ich nicht mehr alle.
Oh nein, das ist doch ein Schatz. Bitte nichts davon weggeben. Wenn du es nicht mehr haben willst, schickst du es mir. Ich kenne Leute, ich habe sich die Grüße an Legende verloren. Und das Deutsche Fußballmuseum ja auch. Also die haben sich da nach die Hände.
Ja, ich habe ja auch ein gutes Verhältnis.
Ja, das glaube ich.
Gestern stand, aber habe ich ja auch schon erzählt, da hat die mich, die kam von der Theke, mich angesprochen, Kleinhans. Ich sage ja, woher kennst du mich denn mal? Ja, ich kenne dich. Na ja, gut und schön, das hast du nur nebenbei bemerkt. Aber weißt du was, es gibt so Abstriche im Leben, die du auch hast, die dir willkommen sind, wo du dich nicht drüber geärgert hast. Hast aber auch welche dabei, wo du dich mal geärgert hast. Das ist eine ganz normale Sache im Leben eines Menschen. Plus und Minus.
Aber wenn du willst, dann lass doch mal von gestern Abend davon erzählen und darüber sprechen. Du hast gestern die Exklusiv-Premiere der Doku Mädchen können keinen Fußball spielen. Gesehen, die kommt in die ARD Mediathek. Ich werde das auch verlinken, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Findet ihr alles in den Show Notes. Ein Film von Thorsten Körner, in dem ganz, ganz viele Frauen zur Sprache kommen, unter anderem eben auch du. Wie war es denn gestern?
Es war hervorragend. All diejenigen, die dem Interview standen, dann auf der Bühne. Hinter uns war die Leinwand. Entschuldigung. Und ich wurde als Erster aufgerufen, musste mich da ergeben, mit den Fragen beantworten und so weiter.
Na, da hatten sie ja gleich ein paar schöne Anekdoten auf der Bühne.
Jaja. War aber alles lieb und nett aufgezogen. Kann man gar nicht anders sagen. Ich spreche ja immer wieder, dass wir keine negative Zeit hatten. War auch gestern nicht. Es war alles wunderschön vom Thorsten Körner gemacht, der uns auch so vorstellte und immer sehr lieb und nett war zu uns. Wenn er was wissen wollte, hat er gefragt. Er war auch hier einmal schon zu Gast. Da hatte ich noch die alten Fußballspielerinnen eingeladen. Da haben wir hier fröhlich gesessen, Kaffee getrunken. Thorsten hatte Kuchen mitgebracht und hatte noch aus seiner, aus Berlin tätig. Was die für eine Funktion im Frauenfußball hat, hat er bestimmt gesagt. Ich weiß es nur nicht mehr. Die war auch sehr lieb und nett und hat sich nur Tizen gemacht. Ja, das war ein schöner Nachmittag hier. So, um auf die Situation von gestern zurückzukommen, es hat mich gefreut. Ich habe eigentlich auch damit gerechnet, dass man für das Publikum uns auch irgendwie auf die Bühne bieten würde. Und da war ich, weil ich die Alte bin, die Älteste, dass ich vielleicht als Erste rankomme. Ja, so war es dann auch. Und dann wurde eigentlich gefragt, die Fragen, die du auch gestellt hast an mich, es ist schön, dass das immer eine Wiederholung ist. Das heißt also, man wird älter, ein Kopf kann es auch nachlassen, dass du das dann nicht mehr abspeicherst. Aber wenn man so Einladungen bekommt, und du freust dich, das habe ich gestern in einem Satz auch gesagt, wenn man älter wird, dann freut man sich, wenn man wieder mal zu einem Gespräch eingeladen wird. So ungefähr habe ich mich ausgedrückt. Das musste ich da einwerfen, weil es ja auch stimmte. Ich glaube, ich bin die Älteste, auch vom Publikum her. Ist auch nur nebensächlich. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie lange ich da gefragt worden bin. Weiß ich nicht mehr. Ich habe eben das gesagt, was du vorhin auch fragtest, dann habe ich dann geantwortet. Und dann wurde das Gespräch weiter an die Anne-Kathrin. Moment, wie heißt sie denn?
Anne-Trabant Habach.
Ach ja, Trabach. Die hat auch lange gequatscht. Und dann zum Schluss hat die... Mensch, wie heißt sie? Geht sie jetzt noch? Mein Alter.
Vielleicht war Hannelore Ratzeburg noch dort? Ich konnte leider eben nicht vor Ort sein.
Warte mal, doch, die hat auch gespielt, aber die hat...
Es sind so viele Spielerinnen, dass ich jetzt leider nicht alle Namen hier runter ratten will. Aber wie hat dir denn der Film gefallen und was waren denn deine Gedanken dabei? Weil du im Film kommst du ja drin vor, aber relativ am Anfang, du bist quasi der Anfang einer Entwicklung und dann sieht man, welche Widerstände die Frauen nach dir zu bewältigen hatten.
Der Aufbau war gut, dass man von Anfang an, wo das Verbot bestand, dass man da die Aufnahmen machte und wie ich dir vorhin sagte, im letzten Spiel, da wo ich diesen rosa Pullover an hatte, weiß ich, hatte ich gestern nämlich nicht an. Da hat der Thorsten Körner mich auch schon interviewt, aber seine Sprache war nicht, sondern nur meine Antworten waren immer da. Da habe ich gedacht, oh, hast ja noch einen dicken Kopke.
Es ist auch immer, es ist auf Film anders, als man sich selbst sieht. Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Nein, nein, es war schön. Die Zeit vor einem Jahr, die war sehr schön. Und jetzt im April durften wir nochmal wieder kommen. Da hat er uns diese Dokumentation von seinem Fußball, den hat er uns da vorgeführt. Wir sind sehr herzlich aufgenommen worden. Ich hatte die Waldrad mitgenommen und so.
Und das ist ja schön, dass die Frauen jetzt wieder eine Bühne bekommen. Und wie denkst du denn über die Entwicklung des Fußballs der Frauen nach eben deiner Zeit, die ja auch jetzt in der Doku bearbeitet wurde? Ich habe zum Beispiel gelesen, dass du den Dortmunder versuchen, Frauenfußball dann umzusetzen, erst kritisch gegenüberstand. Ich weiß aber gar nicht, ob das noch eine aktuelle Meinung von dir ist, denn die sind ja durchaus erfolgreich.
Das muss ich überlegen. Kritisch?
Na, du hast mal gesagt, die spielen dir nicht gut genug. Du gehst lieber ins Westfalen-Stadion.
Ja, habe ich das gesagt.
Aber das ist auch schon ein paar Jahre her. Da waren ja noch ein paar Ligen, die sind ja jetzt immer aufgestiegen. Soweit jetzt ja aus der Westfalen-Liga.
Da gebe ich keinen Kommentar dazu. Mag sein, dass ich es gesagt habe. Aus welchem Grund auch immer, weiß ich nicht. Aber vielleicht war ich der Meinung, das stimmt, was du jetzt sagst. Ich habe mich da jetzt bedeckt. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich kann mich nicht äußern.
Aber warst du mal bei den BVB-Frauen jetzt, nachdem du ja beim BVB bei den Männern eine Dauerkarte hast?
Ja, du sag mal, ich habe plötzlich eine Einladung bekommen, das war das, das ist auch wichtig für dich, das erste Frauenfußballspiel Frauenmannschaft von BVB gegen 1860 München. Ich glaube, ich weiß es auch nicht, vor zwei oder drei Jahren. Du, da hat mich der Vorstand eingeladen.
Ja, super.
Der Kramer, den kennst du ja auch. Und dann, das war der Vorsitzende, wie heißt der?
Aki Watzke.
Nein, nicht Watzke, der war gar nicht da.
Ach so.
Mein Alter kommt jetzt durch.
Und meine Unkenntnis auch. Aber der Vorstand von BVB hat ihn.
Den muss ich unbedingt erwähnen. Der hat aufgehört jetzt, der war im Vorstand. Rauball, Dr. Rauball.
Ach so, na klar. Das hätte mir aber auch einfallen müssen.
Die beiden haben mich im Stadion empfangen. Auf einmal kam eine Durchsage durch den Lautsprecher. Ja, wir begrüßen auch Christa Kleinhans, die Fußball gespielt hat. Das ist ja ganz los, voll. Und dann musste ich zu den beiden Männern hin. Die hatten mir ein Trikot geschenkt. Kleinhans stand oben drauf. Und dann hatten die so einen Spaß. Dann habe ich die erstmal geherzt, habe mich bedankt worden, dass die so nett waren und schenken mir ein Fußballtrikot. Jetzt habe ich da oben im Kleiderschrank drei oder vier von Anfang an und so. Ja, das sind alles so Sachen, die du registrierst. Und dann habe ich mir das Fußballspiel angesehen. Ja gut, ich vergleiche dann immer so, das ist nicht sportlich fair mit uns. Ich muss auch die Klappe halten. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich war nur so der Meinung, die haben nicht besser gespielt als wir damals. Damals war eine andere Zeit.
Ja, und natürlich, ihr wart dann auch allen Widerständen zum Trotz. Ihr wart im Training, ihr wart eine eingeschworene Mannschaft. Ihr erkanntet euch, ihr habt in derselben Konstellation sehr, sehr häufig gespielt. Und beim BVB damals, bei diesem ersten Spiel gegen 1860, das war ja quasi die Gründung der BVB-Frauenabteilung, wenn ich mich jetzt richtig erinnere. Da war ja damals das Bestreben des BVB, bis heute ja, das von Grund auf neu aufzubauen. Sich nicht eben die Lizenz eines anderen Vereins zu holen oder mit jemandem zu fusionieren, sondern ganz unten anzufangen. Dementsprechend können die noch nicht so lange miteinander gespielt haben.
Ich glaube, die steigern auch auf jetzt.
Ja, die sind aufgestiegen.
Die sind aufgestiegen. Und wer mich da auch noch empfangen hat, die hat gestern neben mir gesessen. Die hat, ich weiß, die auch schon über 100 Länder spiele. Mensch, wie heißt sie denn? Anne Ratke? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich halte mal die Klappe. Sehr, sehr freundlich. Die und noch eine aktive Spielerin, die haben mich gebeten, ich möchte noch nach unten kommen. Dann haben wir da auf der Laufbahn gestanden und haben uns gequatscht und wurden dann auch fotografiert. Aber ich wollte nur sagen, das war auch wieder so ein schöner Nachmittag, womit ich gar nicht gerechnet habe. Ich durfte umsonst rein.
Entschuldigung, das ist das Mindeste. Ich habe gelesen, stimmt denn die Geschichte, dass bei der WM 2011 du einen Brief geschrieben hast an Hannelore Ratzeburg, nämlich um zu fragen, ob ihr Tickets bekommt für Weltmeisterschaftsspiele und ihr nur ein Rabatt eingeräumt bekommen hättet?
Ich habe mich über die so aufgeregt, das habe ich dir auch am Telefon gesagt. Und wie habe ich gestern wiedergesehen, in Ratzeburg. Genau, aber es ist ja jetzt auch schon 50 Jahre her. Nein, das ist passé.
Aber es zeigt ja, wie euphemistisch gesagt, schwer sich der DFB bis in die jüngste Vergangenheit damit getan hat, das anzuerkennen, was Frauen wie du geleistet haben.
Ich weiß ja auch nicht, was die geleistet haben. Männer aus ihrer passiven Zeit uns so nach vorne zu bringen, dass das Verbot aufgehoben wurde. Das waren eigentlich Sachen, da haben wir uns gar nicht drum gekümmert. Wir haben uns nur darum gekümmert, wann haben wir denn das nächste Spiel? Wirklich, es gab für uns nur die aktive Zeit, Fußball zu spielen, was alles in geschlossenen Räumen verhackstückt wurde, hat uns nicht interessiert. Hauptsache, uns geht es gut, man verbietet uns das nicht. Das Verbot bestand ja bis 1970, da wurde es aufgehoben. Da habe ich dann schon fünf Jahre nicht mehr gespielt. Zwischenzeitlich wurde ich zwar schon immer mal angesprochen, da zu spielen, da zu spielen, aber ich habe das immer so mit der Mannschaft verglichen, in der ich gespielt habe. Da hatte ich keinen Bock.
Du warst zu erfolgreich und deswegen konntest du nicht mehr auf eine niedrigere Runde.
Ja, war ich. Ich will nicht eingebildet sein, wenn ich das so wiedererzähle, aber das sind alles Tatsachen. Manchmal hört sich das so übertrieben an. Und 65, wie gesagt, aufgehört und dann bis 75 Handball gespielt, war auch schön. Aber jetzt vom Charakter her, der Mannschaft, hat mir die Fußballzeit besser gefallen als die Handballzeit. Wir hatten eine wunderbare, wirklich, wir hatten ja einmal, glaube ich, wir hatten auch oft Einladungen, wo wir gegen Mannschaften, die in der Bundesliga, haben die da schon in der Bundesliga gespielt, Witten hat ein Jahr, dann habe ich aber aufgehört.
In der Handball-Bundesliga, ja genau.
Habe ich aufgehört, Handball zu spielen, dann ging ich zum Kegelsport. Also ich war immer aktiv, ja.
Ja, das, auch deshalb glaube ich, können wir hier noch so ein schönes Gespräch über so lange Zeit führen. Aber was sind denn deine Gedanken zur aktuellen Stellung des Frauenfußballs? Ich muss sagen, wenn ich das mal kurz vorschieben darf, meine Perspektive, mich macht es richtig wütend, zu sehen, welchen großen Andrang es früher schon bei Spielen von Frauen gab. Und du hast es ja gesagt, es war nicht aus Häme, sondern da haben sich Leute für diesen Sport interessiert. Und dafür, dass Frauen diesen Sport eben auf einem schönen Niveau betreiben, dem man eben einfach gerne zuguckt. Und mich macht das wütend, dass dann, obwohl 1970 schon das Verbot zwar aufgehoben wurde, aber dass es dann so viele Jahrzehnte dauert, bis man, man ist ja immer noch nicht annähernd auf einer, ich will gar nicht Gleichstellung sagen zum Männerfußball, weil eigentlich kann es auch egal sein, was die Männer gemacht haben. Aber dass das so viele Jahrzehnte gedauert hat und jetzt ist zwar vieles besser geworden, aber man mag sich gar nicht ausmachen, was gewesen wäre, wäre es von Anfang an wenigstens ungefähr gleich behandelt worden.
Ich glaube, der Druck der Frauen, der Mädchen, der war so stark, dass 1970 der DFB nachgehen musste. Aber im Hintergedanken immer, irgendwann werden die aufhören. Dann werden wir die gar nicht mehr anerkennen und so weiter. Aber die wussten nicht, was das für ein Druck von unten kam. Und da musste sie natürlich helle sein wollen und haben das also dann nicht abgebrochen. Und das war dann auch die Zeit, da habe ich mich gar nicht drum gekümmert. Sollen sie noch zu sehen, wie sie da klarkommen? Verbot ist aufgehoben worden. Nun sollen sie das bringen, was sie können in der Mannschaft, dass sie weiter kämpfen, denn wir haben zehn Jahre gekämpft, wirklich gekämpft. Und die sollen auch weiter kämpfen, dass sie den Bestand behalten. Jetzt haben wir das Verbot, haben wir gebrochen, wir dürfen Fußball spielen. Weiß ich nicht, meine Gedanken. Vielleicht haben einige auch so gedacht, wir müssen Fußball spielen. Ich weiß es nicht, ich bin auch gar nicht weiter in die Vereine gegangen, um mich zu erkundigen, wie geht es euch denn, habt ihr alles gut gemacht und so weiter.
Du hast ein Stück weit abgeschlossen mit dem Fußball.
Es war abgeschlossen. Die schöne Zeit war abgeschlossen. Als wir unten waren, vom Notar, war die Fußballzeit für mich zu Ende. Ich hätte jetzt, wiederhole mich auch wieder, aber, Herr Mike Bertha, 88, diese Monate, ich möchte noch so gerne Fußball spielen. Aber es ist ein Wunschgedanke. Da sagen einige, die Alte ist bekloppt. Ja, was hat die denn jetzt schon in dem Hohen Arzt?
Aber kennst du, ich weiß gerade nicht, heißt das G-Fußball? Es gibt eine Art des Fußballs, bei der Rennen mehr oder weniger oder wirklich verboten ist. Das ist tatsächlich für Menschen, die aus welchen Gründen auch immer nur noch diese Art von Fußball spielen können. Vielleicht. Ich kenne jemanden, der spielt aus dem Bielefeld. Vielleicht kann ich euch verbinden.
Nein, nein, gar nicht. Ich weiß nicht, man tickte vorher anders so. Wenn irgendetwas vorbei ist, was du geliebt hast, so habe ich gedacht. Ich will das auch jetzt so sagen. Schluss aus, feierabend. Spielst du kein Fußball mehr, obwohl ich, wie ich vorhin schon sagte, angesprochen wurde, du hast zu Fußball gespielt. Willst du nicht zu uns kommen? Ich hatte keinen Bock. Ich habe immer an unsere Mannschaft gedacht, das sagte ich vorhin auch, wie wir uns rein menschlich gut verstanden haben. Wir haben trainiert. All das, was verboten war, haben wir versucht, zu durchbrechen. Und irgendwie haben wir immer so einen Schlupf gehabt, wo wir durchbrechen konnten. Nur manchmal hat uns die Jahreszeit mit der Dunkelheit geärgert, wenn wir also frei hatten vom Beruf aus.
Das fand ich interessant. Ich habe gelesen, dass manchmal dann die Freunde und manchmal auch Ehemänner der Spielerin ihre Opel-Kapitäne an Spielverdreht haben. Und weißt du, was daran so frappierend ist an dieser Geschichte? Also die haben dann eben ihre Lichter angemacht und so hattet ihr dann Licht und konntet Fußball spielen.
Gut, dass du das sagst. Das stimmt.
Anfang der 2000er hat Katrin Lengert, die später mit dem FC Bayern, unter anderem mit dem FC Bayern auch Erfolge hatte, Torfrau war auch im Nationalteam, hat jetzt ein tolles Buch geschrieben, kann ich dir gerne mal schicken. Die hat das Anfang der 2000er auch noch erlebt. Bei Duisburg damals. Ja, aber irgendwie auch nicht schön, oder?
Ach, weißt du was? Was soll ich eine Kritik machen, von der ich nichts weiß, nicht erlebt hab, mich nicht drum gekümmert hab, kann ich nicht, ja. Ich bin nur immer der Meinung, und dabei bleibe ich. Vorher war alles anders. Ob es sportlich war, familiär anders, Ehe anders. Das kann ich alles beweisen. Ja, es war so. Wo ich dann, mich durchgesetzt hab, brauchte ich nicht bei meinen Eltern, nur bei meinem Ehemann. Und dann hab ich Schluss. Da war ich geschieden. Na ja, gut und schön. Auch das haben wir gut hinter uns gebracht. Es sind so einige Sachen, weißt du. Da freu ich mich, dass ich tatsächlich doch den Entschluss gepackt hab. Schluss aus, Feierabend. Jetzt geht's los. Scheidung. Ist eine Ansichtssache.
Und jetzt sprechen wir ja kurz bevor die Fraune im Los geht. Willst du gucken?
Ach, weißt du was? Ich bin nicht mehr so neugierig, dass ich mich so darauf freue, du guckst. Wenn ich Zeit habe, mach ich dich.
Du hast zu viele BVB-Spiele der Männer gesehen.
Die hab ich.
Die haben dir die Freude genommen. Ja, ich weiß.
Ich hab ja auch für die nächste Saison.
So soll es ja auch sein. Aber ich hab gelesen, dass du durchaus manchmal, auch zum Teil ja mit Anne noch, als ihr noch zusammen im Stadion wart, dass ihr doch auch durchaus mal 15 Minuten vor Ende des Spiels gegangen seid, wenn ihr gesehen habt, das wird heute eh nix mehr.
Wir gehen meistens in der 80. Minute nach Hause. Und warum? Wir fahren ja da mit dem Bus, der steht da ziemlich an der B1. Du musst also da noch ja zu Fuß vom Stadion aus, je nachdem, wie du drauf bist, 10 bis 15 Minuten. Dann stehen da die Busse alle aufgerichtet. Denn mit den Bussen sind wir in Barob, da an der Uni, sind wir eingestiegen. Und der Bus hatte uns bis zum Stadion, nicht zum Stadion, sondern da, wo er halten konnte, hat er uns hingebracht. Und das Gleiche ging dann für die Rückfahrt, ja. So war das. Und wären wir bis zum, meistens sind ja immer 3, 4 Minuten noch Verlängerung nach der 19. Minute. Das wäre alles zu voll geworden auf dem Weg zum Bus hin. Nee, haben wir gesagt, entweder gewinnen sie das Spiel oder sie kriegen gleich noch einen rein. Ja, 80. Minute, weg waren wir. Hab ich noch nie bereut. Ja, dann hörten wir im Bus schon. Da hatten einige dann das Radio an. Ich sag, wie steht's denn da? Ja, so und so. Waren wir alle zufrieden.
Aber bist du, warst du beim Spiel gegen Malaga damals im Stadion?
Ach, ich war mal in den Ausland. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich könnte ja sagen.
Weil das wäre sehr traurig, wenn du da früher gegangen wärst. Das war das, wo man dann.
Hier in Dortmund?
Ja, ja, last minute noch gewonnen. Das war, aber vielleicht ja.
Ich kann es dir ehrlich nicht beantworten. Das ist ja schon ein paar Jahrzehnte her.
Ein paar Jahrzehnte? Ja, doch inzwischen schon über ein Jahrzehnt. Aber ja, jetzt merke ich selber gerade dran, dass ich auch alt werde langsam. Ja, aber du bist im Fußball weiter verbunden, auch wenn du für dich persönlich abgeschlossen hast damit. Und ich nehme mit aus dem Gespräch. Ich erlebe dich als sehr ausgeglichen und du bist im Reinen, nicht nur mit dir, das gibt mich ja gar nichts an, wie du persönlich mit dir im Reinen bist, aber eben mit deiner Geschichte als Fußballspielerin, auch dass es dann irgendwann vorbei war und wie im Grunde dein Verhältnis zum Fußball dein Leben lang war.
Ja, meine Liebe und mein Ehrgeiz zum Fußball ist schon als Kind da. Und jetzt habe ich auch noch, sonst hätte ich keine Dauerkarte bei BVB. Und ich freue mich jedes Mal, wenn sie gewinnen. Und vor allen Dingen freue ich mich mehr, wenn sie gut gespielt haben. Aber das letzte Spiel war ja wieder fürchterlich.
Welches meinst du jetzt, das letzte in der Bundesliga?
Bundesliga, Bundesliga, ach, die waren furchtbar. Das spielte alles nur im Mittelfeld, dieses Kurzpassspiel links, rechts, wieder nach hinten. Habe ich gedacht, Mensch, wann werden die Außen denn mal...
Ja klar, du wirst natürlich, dass der Rechtsaußen, der muss alle Welle bekommen, was Christa...
Die müssen bedient werden, die Linken und die Rechten. Aber das war alles nicht... Huuu, hab dich das geärgert. Na ja, gut, geh ich eben nach Hause. Ja, so sind so die Meinungen. Ich weiß nicht, ob auch so viele gedacht haben, jeder hat so seine eigene Meinung, soll er auch vertreten, wenn er meint, die ist richtig. Ja, so war das.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch drei Fragen an dich.
Tu das.
Das eine, wenn du dir, du hast dem Fußball so viel gegeben, dem deutschen Fußball, wenn du dir vom Fußball etwas wünschen könntest, was wäre das?
Was ich vorhin schon gesagt habe, jetzt Fußball spielen.
Also, dass du noch mal Fußball spielen könntest?
Nochmal 70 Jahre jünger sein. Das wäre jetzt... Ach, das ist eine übertriebene Sache, übertriebene Wunschgedanke. Aber du hast mich danach gefragt, das ist eigentlich meine Antwort auf diese Frage. Würde ich gerne, ja. Vor allen Dingen, weil alles anders ist, wenn ich an die Zeit denke, wie wir zehn Jahre gekämpft haben, um überhaupt Fußball spielen zu dürfen und höhere Gewalt eben, dann war, dass wir nicht mehr bestückt waren, elf Mädchen da zusammen zu kriegen, ja. Deshalb wäre das ein Wunsch von mir, noch mal, die Mädchen können ja wunderbar Fußball spielen. Das ist ja ein Aufbau, den ich bei der Mannschaft vom BVB vermisse.
Ich meine, das deutsche Frauen-Nationalteam spielt auch Flügelastiker.
Ach, was soll man alles quaken.
Wir haben es ja alle selber gesehen. Aber ich will jetzt nicht über Nico Kovac sprechen. Wir hatten so ein schönes Gespräch.
Ich sehe nicht den Kovac.
Als Typ wunderbar. Ich glaube auch, dass er nur gute Intentionen hat. Aber ich glaube, dass er ab einem gewissen Punkt seinen Teams nicht mehr helfen kann, dabei mit Ball am Fuß einen guten Fußball zu spielen. Es ist ein pragmatischer Fußball, der auch auf ein hohes Niveau führt. Aber für das Top-Niveau, was Dortmund braucht gegen tief stehende Gegner, ich habe meine Zweifel ehrlich.
Die müssen gute Spielerinnen, gute Spieler bekommen jetzt für die nächste, im August fängt das Jahr an, für die Bundesliga zu spielen. Ich hoffe, sie kaufen gut ein. Ich weiß ja auch nicht, wen sie verlieren. Ich hoffe Bellingham, dass der seine Tore macht, wie sein Bruder.
Das sind natürlich auch große Fußstapfen. Aber das ist jetzt nochmal was anderes.
So, zweite Frage.
Die zweite Frage. Was würdest du denn der 18-jährigen Christa sagen, wenn du nochmal mit ihr reden könntest?
Mensch, Christa, hast du eine schöne Zeit verbracht. Wie lange hast du Fußball gespielt? Zehn Jahre? Und?
Na, mit 18 ist es ja noch, bevor du es spielst. Genau, du redest quasi mit der Christa, die jetzt zum ersten Mal zu Fortuna Dortmund.
Ach so, bitte nochmal die Frage.
Ja, also was würdest du der jungen 18-jährigen Christa sagen, die zu ihrem ersten Training zu Fortuna Dortmund geht?
Zum Training? Da gehe ich gar nicht hin, bei Borussia Dortmund.
Nein, nein, Fortuna Dortmund, du redest quasi mit deinem früheren selbst. Ach so. Also, was hättest du vielleicht anders gemacht oder hättest du vielleicht mehr genossen?
Weißt du was, das ist eine Frage, die ich nicht beantworten kann. Zeitversetz, in die heutige Zeit jetzt gelegt, denkt man anders. Denkt man anders, man fordert auch mehr von den Mädchen. Und vielleicht hätte ich das gemacht. Da kann ich dir keine ehrliche Antwort geben, weil ich das anders erlebt habe und aber auch die Zeit wirklich genossen habe. Deshalb weiß ich nicht, was hätte ich wirklich gemacht. Ich weiß es nicht. Zweite Frage war das.
Genau. Und jetzt die letzte Frage. Was würdest du den jungen Mädchen sagen, die Fußball spielen wollen? Welchen Rat würdest du denen mitgeben?
Mädchen, wenn du das Talent hast, Fußball zu spielen, kümmer dich darum, dass du in der Bundesliga einen Platz findest. Ja, guck mal, was ist denn in deiner Heimat, in deiner Stadt los? Gibt es da einen Bundesliga-Verein? Dann geh doch mal hin und guck.
Sehr gut. Christa, wir könnten noch ewig weitersprechen, aber es ist unfassbar warm und ich möchte dir jetzt eine Pause geben. Vielen, vielen Dank für deine Zeit. Es hat große Freude gemacht.
Das gebe ich dir zurück. Hat mir auch Freude gemacht mit dir.
Das ist schön. Danke dir.
Das habe ich gerne gemacht.
Ja, und das war mein Gespräch mit Christa Kleinhans. Ich weiß, dass ihr Feedback zu dieser Folge haben werdet. Ich bin unheimlich gespannt darauf, das zu lesen. Ich freue mich schon sehr darauf und ich habe mir für diese Sendung etwas überlegt. Und zwar zum einen könnt ihr natürlich sehr gerne wieder unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de mir Nachrichten schicken zu dieser Sendung. Und weil ich aber weiß, dass das für Christa jetzt kein Weg sein wird, da ins Forum reinzugucken, hätte ich eine Idee. Und zwar, wenn ihr wollt, dann schickt ihr doch sehr gerne entweder per E-Mail an max.rasenfunk.de Feedback und ich drucke das dann aus. Und werdet ihr das dann zu ihrem Geburtstag am 22. Juli schicken. Oder wenn ihr sogar ein Brief oder ein Kärtchen oder sonst was loswerden wollt, dann findet ihr in den Show Notes die Adresse der Rasenfunk GmbH. Und da kann das dann hingehen. Und dann würde ich ihr als kleine Überraschung zu ihrem Geburtstag ein kleines Päckchen fertig machen. Da lege ich dann auch das Buch von Kathrin Lengardt rein. Wir verdienen mehr. Das habe ich ja auch kurz angesprochen im Interview. Und ich glaube, dass Christa sich darüber unheimlich freuen würde und auf diesem Weg dann eben auch mitbekommt, dass das hier von Leuten gehört wird. Denn, wie jetzt nicht anders zu vermuten, ist Podcast nicht das erste Medium gewesen, das ihr eingefallen wäre, wenn ich gefragt hätte, wo möchtest du denn ein Interview geben? Und logischerweise kann sie es, obwohl ich es ihr erklärt habe, wahrscheinlich auch nicht so ganz einschätzen, was wir hier eigentlich machen. Also, wenn ihr auf diese Art und Weise Feedback geben wollt, sehr, sehr gerne, entweder an max.rasenfunk.de. Das drucke ich dann aus, so wie in der guten alten Zeit. Oder ihr könnt auch gerne, wenn ihr es persönlicher haben wollt, ein Kärtchen, einen Brief, was auch immer, an die Adresse schicken, die in den Show Notes steht. Ich setze darauf, dass ihr wie immer verantwortungsvoll mit dieser Aufgabe oder diesem Angebot eigentlich umgeht. Und ansonsten kann ich euch nur empfehlen, schaut euch die Doku an. Mädchen können kein Fußball spielen von Thorsten Körner. Das ist verlinkt in den Show Notes. Und ihr könnt auch sehr gerne ins letzte Tribünengespräch reinhören. Da haben wir über einen ebenfalls ganz grandiosen Film gesprochen. Copa 71 über die WM in Mexiko 1971. Dazu ist ja das letzte Tribünengespräch erschienen. Danke auch für das tolle Feedback auf diese Sendung. Und es ist auch schön zu sehen, dass wirklich einige von euch deswegen ins Kino gegangen sind. So soll das doch sein. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit und danke für euren Support. Denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Thorin, bei Real Hanswurst, bei Max aus Köln, bei Daklingets und bei Villa Tivoli. In diesem Sinne, wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de, einfach auf den Unterstützen-Button klicken. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das getan haben, denn ihr wisst, ihr haltet den Rasenfunk damit am Laufen. In diesem Sinne, Feedback sehr gerne unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de oder auf dem besprochenen Weg. Abonniert sehr gerne diesen Feed hier, bewertet ihn gern, wenn ihr wollt und vor allem empfehlt doch diese Sendung auch sehr gerne weiter. Denn ich bin mir ganz, ganz sicher, sehr viele Menschen haben noch nicht von Christa Kleinhans gehört und werden sich aber, wenn sie dieses Gespräch gehört haben, ärgern, dass sie vorher noch nicht von ihr gehört haben. Das ist zumindest meine Vermutung. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, danke, dass ihr das hier möglich gemacht habt. Bleibt gesund, bleibt uns gewogen und bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Ciao!
Das war der Rasenfunk, von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank.